too welcome everybody and happy
Halloween we are back baby
[Applause]
is that like a like a I'm like a spooky
whaling ghost
s like Thanksgiving isn't it
is until next month you don't find that
sound like a turkey you'll find that
scary
that's turkey
welcome guys it's Halloween this is our
first episode back uh officially we did
uh we put out the ghost hunting video on
Saturday which you all should check out
last Sunday but we are back after our
long forced Hiatus yeah the powers have
conspired against us to come down
unfairly probably fairly on me
who's this episode brought to you by
today's sponsors are stamps.com and
gamer sup Nation
[Applause]
it's gonna be a long night baby I want
to hit this up mm-hmm
cherries yes so we obviously have a lot
to talk about I've missed you guys
dearly
miss doing the shows just [ __ ] suck
dude talk to me baby but here let's
let's go over everyone's costumes
everyone we all kind of went all out
this year I wanted to prove to everybody
that I am indeed not a theater kid
[Laughter]
and that Frenemies doesn't I don't need
Frenemies to spend fifteen hundred
dollars on all costs
so obviously I'm paying me I'm penguin a
lot of people said uh there was a
conversation about penguin brain but I
think more than that everybody was very
generous to point out that I look like
penguin so thank you guys
all right yeah you can't really see the
full shot I guess but I'm I'm All About
I'm all out
um took like three and a half four hours
and uh boy they did an incredible job
and of course joined with me today is my
uh partner in crime a cat woman
[Music]
and she is looking fine baby in that
leather where's that whip girl um
I actually don't have that stomp on it I
will stomp on you later are you well
all right all right talk to me baby yeah
how do you feel it's very revealing
obviously yeah I know not to I mean
you're you're saying that that's why I'm
pointing it out yeah I was saying I feel
very exposed do you want to stand up or
not but sure okay yeah
but anyway
um
oh sorry just a little bit of uh what
sorry I just uh I had a little bit of
God I had a little indigestion excuse me
anyway
Dan do you want to tell us who has your
address says
I'm the Primal King himself the lettuce
King
[Music]
the lightest king that's in a direct
challenge dude that's right liver King
Supremacy that's right the liver King is
uh subprimal uh wow yep he doesn't eat
his greens everybody knows that you need
greens to stay healthy and uh that's
exclusively what I eat okay that's right
so let me ask you can we see your boobs
can you move back a little bit damn bro
you got the X-Men you just eating
lettuce got some good songs
my muscles are so big they've actually
consumed the nipples oh it's just like
wrapped around them I've seen that
before yeah
I'll tell you I'll tell you how yeah uh
uh uh lettuce King
do you eat any meat are you smelling
yeah strictly vegan perfectly vegan no
no animal products no animal products no
honey no milk
never talk about my wife yeah and tell
and let me ask you this when you're
having sex with your wife what sexual
position are you guys usually doing
there
my wife and I
we have a very uh open relationship when
it comes to sexuality so uh I'm happy to
talk about that with you in great detail
in every way
Gladys King is open about his second
absolutely I'm not gonna be ashamed of
there not going to be ashamed of them no
of course not well we'll touch on that
later uh I hope so uh uh I hate to say
it but a B has racially profiled himself
yeah I'm wearing an old costume an
aladdin costume you got the Fizz on and
everything bro yep I got the Fizz the
Fizz and uh yeah I'm I'm more of an
accessory to Lena's house yeah Lena
looks amazing thank you a little show
you know we'll just skip over maybe real
fast damn that looks amazing princess oh
Amy's coming over there
take a foot I'm the accessory yeah and
then will you guys do this I can show
you the world
anybody
Olivia
show anybody
you want us to jump in and say do what
no I want them to do it
I
can't sing I can't sing
yeah yeah yeah yeah
very nice thank you thank you
wow it's like the live action Aladdin
all over again yep
oh man and then moving on we have uh
Olivia do you want to explain yours
I am the H3 podcast until at least 2023.
what do you mean by that the best behave
just a little indigestion it's not a big
deal sorry excuse you appear to be
vomiting on yourself you're leaking
poison yeah no no no no no I'm good it
happens every it happens around this
time every day okay
fine
uh you are uh the H3 podcast through
2023 you're that is me yeah I am a nun
I'm a perfect angel not just to the 3023
[Music]
[Applause]
bury my ass I'll be a bury my virgin ass
oh Dion Jesus your drool has like keyed
out your face
because it's green it is yeah it looks
blue on the previewer
[Laughter]
and then uh moving on Sam you gotta show
it off we have poison ivy keeping the
Batman
Sam you created this dress is that right
I'm sorry what'd you say you made that
dress I had uh the glittery base and
then I added all the leaves and stuff to
it so dude poison ivy
[Applause]
and so if Sam is poison ivy it would
stand to believe that Ian would be Mr
Freeze
Ian
what the [ __ ] is that
uh not quite Mr Freeze
um I'm curious the audience even would
be able to guess what I am
no God here I have the let me see I have
a Thing Once you told me it's all I see
now yeah you try to
okay now yeah maybe now
I meant to be Zuck in the metaverse yeah
the meat Chef himself yeah ladies and
gentlemen we love to see it
Zachariah the Ghost Hunter Zachary look
at his fly who are you meant to be a
disco disco stew
wait yeah there we go look at those
shoes wait move your foot around so they
can see it moves
the fish went around it's not real fish
is it no it's not real fish uh I'm Dirk
Diggler okay good I'm a huge [ __ ]
I'm any poor name but you can call me
Rocky Irwin there [ __ ] okay they're
particular was the dude from Boogie
Nights right yeah but it's not he wasn't
a real person was he it was based on
John Holmes but uh but I'm just like a
70s guy that's what I'm going for okay
fantastic we love to see inside here
and uh Camille Camille
Kim DeLorean
Lauren I Gotta Give a quick shout out to
the guy that made this helmet oh let me
take it off uh Justin that's against the
rules dude oh bro
the costume on
yeah
okay all right shout out just stand
yeah I just don't know what there's
something wrong with you that's not
right it's just you know I have yeah I
have indigestion sometimes too yeah I
don't have acid reflux I don't just
throw up all over myself I didn't throw
up it's just a little bit okay on a big
deal yeah so um
that helmet's amazing what's the war
behind that I mean it's just so
incredibly done
well
I guess sorry it's hot in there uh he
tagged me in this on Instagram and he
said you want to send it to me and not
only did he send this he sent me a bunch
of sweet things in a care package so
thank you very much what a guy
huh thank you thank you so much come on
he 3D printed it himself and he painted
everything it's perfect it's incredible
yeah
sorry to wear bootleg but you know it's
too good not to wear no I don't think we
love Mandalorian helmet it's very good
um and finally uh love all the way over
in Sweden has embraced
being Mr Whiteface and uh well I'm a
ghost first of all but it's like a
double double by me life is not so weird
yeah I stretched out and zoomed in like
from here to be fitting and uh look
yeah show the show the Olivia we gotta
see it yeah that's zoomed out even more
I feel like I like that yeah yeah I'm
also the white gift guy if you search
white on any GIF or any gift search
engine I will be number one it's huge
it's a huge honor I mean yeah you know
what's funny I used to do be the number
one but love Yeah dethroned me yeah
sorry it's been a while since I've uh
yeah donned my white man uh white-faced
man uh Cape there but congratulations on
that love but it's a big achievement
congratulations yeah thank you thank you
guys uh we have a lot of stuff to talk
about should I wipe this so I'm not King
out is it distracting um
bring me just like a paper towel
okay it's just so CR I mean it's
supposed to you know do you want
maybe just touched my spit rag where I
put my bugs
yeah so obviously we gotta talk about
the suspension uh there's a lot of to
talk about there a lot of reactions lots
of opinions you know thank you uh AV and
then we're doing
not oh yeah it is green
oh that helps a lot though when I dab it
looks black at first but then you
realize it's green that that actually
that looks fine right it's not getting
out yeah you're okay
there's a little bit on Your Collar but
that's probably Stained on there now so
what are you gonna do yeah this hat is
giving me a headache I'm gonna take it
off it's like slamming my head there
what happened to my good hairline man oh
I absorbed it
yeah one week band will do to you yeah
we swapped for a week check it out look
at that [ __ ]
damn the flipping it looks kind of dope
on the penguin by the way
it cursed
hello
again again we just wiped it off I can't
help I'm in digestion all right someone
else needs to get the towels now
is it being out it's not
uh it's fine it's fine see
[Laughter]
don't worry Princess Jasmine it got you
covered thank you guys yes thank you I'm
gonna take off my gloves too so I can do
the show
so anyway
um
and also we're going to be revisiting
the uh tier list the candy tier list
there's been a lot of new additions and
also we've put up a
a a poll for our fans on Twitter okay to
uh we put up all the can all the candies
for them to rate ahead of time from F to
S yeah they've already voted we had like
50 000 votes and it's a very interesting
uh results there so we are going to be
amending
the the uh the candy tier list
um
and that's what I'm talking about also
thank you to like uh
thank you to Nathan Sam
um
super cool
all right man we got a lot to get to man
okay so first off I want to say
thank a happy birthday Ela
two oh happy birthday to Teddy fresh
thank you five years
yes
why a lot happened in five years eh yeah
yes indeed happy [ __ ] birthday
to me loser
but the shirt actually still actually
really cool I was gonna wear this shirt
but obviously I'm the penguin but it's
kind of a Vibe isn't it yeah I'm
definitely gonna wear it when it's my
birthday oh yeah with the hat and
everything
yeah it's just happy birthday to me
loser I kind of felt like it
like whenever it's my birthday I I don't
know there's always like
feelings of like also sadness for some
reason I feel like a lot of people
experience that well it's just you know
the inevitable March towards our
immunity
but it's also like people are never
you're always like disappointed because
nobody cares about you right yeah I mean
once you're not like a little kid I
don't know birdies are a little bit
depressing yeah for sure I I don't get
depressed about getting older I just get
I just think like wow nobody cares about
me nobody loves you you know no you
didn't I'm gonna send you a novel at
midnight this year it's my birthday if
someone isn't telling me happy birthday
at least like once on the hour I'll feel
you started say anything yeah no of
course
because it's like on the one hand you
don't want to do anything and then on
the other hand you feel bad you're not
doing anything right it's stupid so so
true Queen so true so that's where the
loser came from I don't know it's just
in a feeling but but the hat is a Vibe
too go ahead but besides that
um it's just so cool with Teddy fresh I
don't know it's crazy that it's been
five years and what it's become it's
basically taking over my life
in a good way I love it
and who do you love more Teddy fresh or
me
[Music]
go ahead you thank you just checking
I had to ask
can I put you on a lie detector yes all
right bring it out you have that ready
go on with my life without you oh
a little penguin Catwoman Alliance look
at that
oh wait okay
come on you old to me
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh great there it is
all right do you think penguin is a good
eats out [ __ ] good yeah for sure for
sure
like he's got to right yeah he doesn't
have to get on his face
that dude eats raw fish bro he just must
Munch that for sure yeah and also I mean
he goes he goes like this lunchtime
I'm not used to having lipstick on it go
ahead how do you maintain that eat out
my ass
this is what I said this is what I say
when I when I see Ela before uh no stars
is gone
you penguin probably likes eating out
women on their periods dude he's [ __ ]
up like that
he goes
he sees this girl in his period and
penguin goes lunch time
can we get a zoom on that I Really Wanna
I don't know if that's possible
technology you could do anything yeah
that's true yeah you ready Ian the green
lunch time I'll do it in post yeah
somebody oh yeah don't worry yeah sorry
about that guys I just I'm the penguin
today
from the penguin the sexual deviant the
penguin there I am
um so we're going to talk about uh sorry
you're you were talking about Teddy
fresh and nice it became lunch time
yes so did you want to finish your
thought or no my thoughts are done and
finished got it sorry about that
yes well I just want to say yeah you
guys are being humble it is really
amazing what you guys built in five
years oh absolutely and uh shout out to
the OG models who are in the office
right now Dan and uh Ian
that kind of model yes they did used to
try the clothes on on me for fits and
stuff in the very early days I know I
was gonna say shoestring yeah it was uh
it is very impressive to see how much
it's grown into you know this big
blossoming company uh I was there at the
very beginning in those initial meetings
in our old uh dentist office in the San
Fernando Valley unemployed with one
employee and you guys and uh and and me
off in the corner and uh and now you
know there's dozens of employees we got
our own building and everything it's
it's really cool to see it involve it
well thank you guys so happy you happy
fifth birthday to Teddy fresh Gila yeah
congratulations be proud of yourself be
proud also I have another a really happy
announcement H3 podcast I think this is
our fifth time but this year I'm playing
ball we have been nominated again for a
streamy award
yes yes yes yes everybody no soft class
it's a very prestigious award so here's
the thing I've rsvp'd yes time that
we're going I've never done that before
and I've always suspected that they
shaft us because they want you there
okay right because like oh you're too
good for our show well [ __ ] your award
[ __ ] I'm gonna give it to Jay Shetty
and by the way I'm up again against Jay
Shetty and I still don't know who the
[ __ ] that is shed it again [ __ ] him dude
I gotta say I love his podcast
unironically I think it's good yeah oh
really it's a [ __ ] head
Mars obviously well what kind of what
kind of show does Shetty do who is it um
it's called on purpose and it's kind of
just like a self-help like perspective I
cannot believe no no offense but I can't
believe self-help
podcast beat us out
like I'm self-help I do everything I
make you laugh I do help yourself I do
everything's just doing one [ __ ]
thing is he funny at all Sam uh no
that's it he's [ __ ] boring and lame
[ __ ] Jay [ __ ] right we gotta be polite
to everybody yeah hold on we want to win
uh he's gonna be a good player and let's
back it up I'll call her daddy obviously
that's a big that show's a big deal
so that I mean they they're probably a
shoe and they're a good chance H3
podcast obviously a huge deal big big
big big big big big big big big deal
yeah huge deal yeah I mean we got
suspended uh for a week it was
international news so true you know it's
not it's kind of a big deal people talk
about us I mean unless when's the last
time you heard about call me daddy you
know what I mean
the last time the last time I heard call
me Daddy was in stepdaughter porn
and Jesus I don't know lunch time lunch
time
[Applause]
uh impulsive I mean I can see them
giving it to him the impulsive has been
kind of a bridesmaid never the bride
like us he's always nominated in
everyone's but he doesn't deserve it
who won it last year
jetty Shetty he wins every year and I
was like who the [ __ ] is Jason wait yeah
I don't know who Mr ballen is no offense
he he tells stories and we love that
about him but okay maybe it'll be him I
don't know man obviously we're the only
it's gonna be Shady you think it
wouldn't I'm calling it now they love
Shetty they're huge running they're huge
shed heads over there and like Sam said
apparently it's a good podcast maybe we
should have Jay on maybe it's time that
would be interesting I'd be open to that
I did put them on the list for people I
would [ __ ] love DJ [ __ ] he's like a
local Legend bro
here's our nominations you guys are
gonna have to update this now this is
our fifth steamy nomination
I'm like Leonardo DiCaprio at this point
wait what happened in 2021
they they didn't nominate us huh which I
thought was insane because obviously
your Frenemies was popping yeah
did they nominate Frenemies as like its
own thing no no no I mean that's the
History Podcast but they no they didn't
nominate us last year number one podcast
in the world thank you Holly yeah
um 2017 were actually nominated for
comedy best comedy series before the
podcast yeah of course we lost that
clearly it's funny and then 8 9 10. best
podcast that's funny because that's when
I feel like
we've improved the show I think without
the degradating our older material 21
they just said [ __ ] you
I have been calling them the Steamers
21. I yeah I think you haven't been
helping yeah the conversation but I'm
all in I want you to know steamy people
are streaming people that I rsvpds were
coming please I'm gonna win stop it just
[ __ ] tell me the oh here's the
here's the nominees from last year Emma
Chamberlain I thought she was going to
win call her daddy again impulsive and
then Jay Shetty and I remember I was
like oh man it's could be either one of
these three I think Jay Shetty one I
said
wait shitty shitty how many times has
[ __ ] been nominated let's see
what the [ __ ] bro
he's out of control man
piece of [ __ ] thing to do here is to get
to know Shetty yeah and join the Chat
Heads movement I'm down I'll see if he
can teach me something right
congratulations to Bailey Syrian by the
way she's a friend of the show we love
her
yeah here's Jay Shetty let's see this is
your IMD page embarrassing 2020 winner
best podcast okay two years ago [ __ ]
time to renew yourself idiot
uh best podcast nominee winner streamy
in 2018 for health and wellness who are
you bro
you got to pick a lane brother
you know
yes wait between what and I know health
and wellness and then he's doing a
podcast stop
well I think it's all related I mean the
podcast is about it let's watch a j
Shady video I want to see what this
[ __ ] I want to see what this guy
talks about on his show all right Jay
Shetty he's probably just such a nice
guy I'm sure Jay is a great guy okay
okay let me just find a short one this
is an hour I'm not watching that [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] I'm not watching that [ __ ]
this man had John Legend on
big [ __ ] names he's Jay [ __ ] shady
man put some respect on the name so wait
oh he has a four million sub Channel and
then a
600 000 podcast Channel who's Jay Shetty
the Creator
[Music]
365 books in one year how did I okay Tai
Lopez
he's the answer
[Music]
hey everyone this is Jay Shetty and
welcome he has beautiful eyes he does I
was just thinking Mom he has gorgeous
eyes that's very funny yeah I mean let's
be real if I had [ __ ] beautiful green
eyes like that I had a one by now hmm
it's like I Justified you think he's
yesified someone but like he that's what
he looks like but he's just the normal
version okay all right here we go his
number one most viewed video if you're
in a long-distance relationship watch
this this is his number one it's only
four minutes let's watch this okay
I've been in a long distance
relationship so uh I have I have some
knowledge on this let's see
[Music]
is this Darman [ __ ] because I'm gonna
lose my mind if it is
[Music]
who wants to lose some money today
[Music]
yeah hi yeah I'm good I'm good you
should I ask if you're good bro she said
hi how about here's the first part about
being a long-term relationship listen
that is good advice right maybe that's
what Jay's gonna say maybe doubt it
staying in ready
[Music]
I can't really talk right now
[Laughter]
[Music]
bro he's just not into her I don't know
what to say foreign
oh no they keep missing each other [ __ ]
bro that's so [ __ ] up man
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
oh my God
I know I know where this is going like I
don't need four minutes for this [ __ ] so
they keep calling they keep missing each
other here's the most watched part
[Music]
yeah I want the shitty summary
the shut the shed Emery complexity
they say distance means so little when
someone means so much but still somehow
distance has this ability to break bonds
to break trust to really push us further
away from each other not just physically
but emotionally bro you're so [ __ ]
boring
you're so charged up I'm back I've been
gone for a week I love sheddy man he's a
good guy I've never seen a YouTube video
where every single comment is about the
same like every comment what are they
they're just long distance relationships
are hard that's pretty much
everything like I mean like they're I
mean that means they paid attention to
the video they're engaged but it's just
it's weird I've never seen a video that
where every comment has basically the
same message well if Sam wasn't here to
say that she's a real [ __ ] I
wouldn't believe that anyone there was
one so I'm glad you're here to confirm
I've never seen the videos actually I've
only ever listened to the podcast so
there it is uh there it is okay so uh
congratulations to
uh Shetty for winning this year's
streamers well he hasn't won yet yeah
he's just giving it away and he's
issuing I'm honestly but be honest what
do you who do you guys think is going to
win for real well the call me daddy
podcast is huge yeah that's like a
fixation so I could see that winning I
don't think they've won one either I
think impulsive on the tweet that the
streamy awards put out where they
announced the nominees yeah most
comments I saw were about H3
oh let's see
let's see
well I did retweet it I don't know if
anyone else did they retweeted
everybody's retweet okay oh someone was
saying they get too much heat if we won
this year because I've been in so much
[ __ ] I've been in so much [ __ ] this
year yeah the timing on the announcement
of the time
still they still gave us an odd which I
appreciate yeah shout out so there it is
the steamy Steamers the steamies take a
steamer on my chest daddy we'll be there
though and I'll bring in my tomatoes in
case we don't win so much Jay Shetty and
he's accepting I'm gonna do a Kanye West
on Jay Shady
[Music]
be careful because everybody used to
know what you were talking about when
you said that but I could literally say
anti-semiticism
at an award show when Taylor Swift was
it Taylor Swift won an award and he went
up during her except the speech and was
like uh uh I'm gonna let you finish
Beyonce should have won okay he was like
a total dude what's new I mean the man's
a [ __ ] lunatic now what
play that whole sound bite it's so
insane
I could say anti-semitic things and
Adidas can't drop me I could literally
say anti-semitic [ __ ] and they can't
drop me now wow what now what now what
Splash cut
Skechers uh escorts Kanye their
headquarters
okay yeah Sketcher said no to him
even TJ Maxx said we're not taking his
shoes PJ Maxx said no to Yeezy
foreign
yeah the street the streamies did bring
us uh I thought I was gay the Fouseytube
yeah oh yeah honestly they deserve a lot
of respect yeah I felt worthless yeah I
felt ugly I felt gay well well
[ __ ] guy I love him all right we got
it so let's see here there's so much
stuff to get to oh my God it's like we
have a billion things to talk about I'm
gonna just look at some top of the show
stuff and then we'll do our my response
to being banned it's a lot of good stuff
to look at there too man
um
I guess uh speaking oh
speaking of birthdays uh birthday
announcement
this Sunday or yesterday actually
uh once this is posted right uh we have
a special surprise
for the birthday boy love hello
sent you a package bro do you have it I
have a little box yeah you want to open
it yeah sure how long have you been
sitting on that uh about probably five
days okay okay have you been tempted to
look inside yeah of course yeah but you
didn't I didn't though I got this little
thing go ahead real
uh oh
hard to open boxes
um
green uh wrapping paper that's it oh yo
inside there is a
some kind of chain you gotta you're
gonna have to hold it up and keep it
still
okay what is it what am I looking it's a
mixture of I think it's a necklace of
some sort uh let's see yeah maybe oh my
goodness yeah try it on let's see there
we go yeah
[Applause]
you better wear that to your beach day
interview
[Applause]
Ice Ice Baby
[Music]
who is this from
um it's from there's a person's it's a
person's individual shop they make this
necklaces they're like one of a kind
each one and oh that's fun I saw this
one with the Ikeas
is that a high fashion purchase actually
um it's like it's it's not like high
fashion necessarily but it's it's a
fashiony website yeah you guys think
that very much you're welcome Happy
Birthday buddy hopefully hopefully your
next one will be celebrated here with us
in person huh yeah hopefully hopefully
yes yes yes we actually have one more
one more thing for him but uh we can't
ship it so
Sam wants to show it off my head is uh
disintegrated okay is it because I'm
sweating
I'm melting From the Inside Out do we
have the white uh it's fine I mean we
have a whole show to do it's gonna get
worse just a tiny bit of white on top
yeah so uh dude does anyone think I look
like [ __ ] zombie Benjamin Franklin
kind of yeah
until you said it I've got like this uh
Founding Father Swag yeah
um Fly this is what happens if the key
on the on the kite experiment went the
wrong way
right like a dash of a dab of white here
I might double do you yo I've been on
such a I've been so good on my diet and
this is my candy day to celebrate
foreign
no this this is a Chick-fil-A number one
combo with Chick-fil-A sauce
you did not it is clean man my very own
dressing Burger yes indeed that you can
have it in Sweden but I don't know I
think this is gonna be a customs
nightmare right we'll hold it for you
we'll hold it yeah well hopefully it'll
be in the US soon take a look at that I
mean the fries are there the chicken
sandwich even the sauce is there that is
I I was very fond of the of the resin
Burger yeah so this is a very exciting
thank you very much Sam thank you thank
you thank you happy birthday buddy we
love you and when you get to America
love the first chicken burger is going
to be on me buddy wow what a guy oh you
did not have to he's already dead again
thank you hey did you ever have an
In-N-Out love did you like that
uh yeah I did yeah okay I liked it the
burgers were Top Class the fries the
fries don't even bother I didn't even
order them yeah yeah yeah yeah all right
let's thank our sponsors and then guys
Jimmy Lee
was on news max did you see this feeling
no they literally interviewed Jimmy Lee
about cancel culture and how comedians
are hamstrung and can no longer dude
and Jimmy fuckingly by the way
uh is Jimmy on the phone to talk about
it no he's being a [ __ ] prick is he
big climbing you yeah he's like I can't
wait around all day for this I'm like
what I'm like [ __ ] you dude like like
what do you want like I'm so over his
[ __ ] well he's so gone to his head to be
fair I don't know how long he's been
waiting yeah we did say we were gonna
take a break you know like between until
we have him on again yeah I was going to
give him out of embargo oh
yeah Ethan made a unilateral uh Power
Play lifting the Embargo early you know
and he's not even going to accept that
invite okay Jimmy
I'm gonna I'm gonna send him the link
and we'll see what happens to be honest
I think it's best that he doesn't see me
in this outfit
the camel jokes are coming
all right I'm sending the link right now
but it's it's so good it's like I
watched that and I said this is my
favorite thing I've seen all year this
is the best I didn't even know that
happened it's incredible it's just
happening okay anyway and they even
introduced him he wrote his own intro
they go Jimmy Lee who's been featured on
the H3 podcast oh my God and you know
news Newsmax is basically like uh Nazi
propaganda
so I'm sure they they probably have done
a story about what a [ __ ] yeah
whoever wrote that segment uh didn't uh
didn't check up on what the History
Podcast anyway thank you quickly to our
sponsors who we love so much first of
all stamps
I love you stamps
you know it's the best service in the
game if you mail or ship anything you're
gonna want to use stamps and the holiday
season's coming up and chaos is always
going to come with it so
right now seasonal excitement or dread
is really starting to settle in
especially for small businesses
uh it's not too late to get your holiday
mailing and shipping under control with
stamps.com
sign up now and you'll be printing your
own postage in minutes here's where it
gets good
it's your One-Stop shop for all your
needs more than 20 years samsung.com has
been indispensable to over a million
businesses get access to the UPS
USPS and UPS services
right from your computer
here's the best part You're Gonna Save
money 86 off postage
holy smokes that's pretty insane up to
up to I don't know I'm trying to
you don't even have to think about it
dude that's true I'm just I'm trying to
you know but up to 86 off that that's
insane and I'm talking USPS and ups and
here's where it gets even better this
the it's so easy it's like a no-brainer
you stamps that come to print postage
from your computer wherever you do
business all uh and and if you need a
pickup you're gonna schedule it they'll
come get it you literally don't have to
leave you don't go anywhere
you leave it on your front door and they
get it you get a digital scale you weigh
it there they send you the scale and
then it tells you how much the postage
is you print it you put it on and then
they come get it and it's cheaper
goddamn
stamps man
it's crazy
you know rates are constantly changing
when Samsung comes switch and save
feature you can easily compare carriers
and rates so you're getting the best
deal every time
uh dance you know we've talked about
this but Dan's girlfriend uses
stamps.com and I think it changed her
life every day changed her life yeah no
but I'm being facetious but it she uses
it yeah no she uses it every day she
runs her own business using it and it's
fantastic yeah
guys uh here's where a really exciting
promo comes in here for you guys this
holiday season trade late night for
silent nights
and get in this clever and get started
with stamps.com today sign up at
stamps.com h3tv for a special offer that
includes a four week trial free postage
and a free digital scale there's no
long-term commitments or contracts just
go to stamps.com h3tv we love you stamps
yeah
and also I'm so excited to be partnered
with the one and only Gamers Nation
Mount oh
I swear to God this game this drink
changed my life
I got so much energy during the show
maybe too much energy if you think about
it is gamer self responsible
you act out you're all Juiced up
no but it gives me so much energy like
good clean energy you know
cleaner than coffee it's so much better
than coffee frame yeah personally I
agree it wakes me up man and then I used
to always get so drowsy on the way home
and it was like so frustrating and I
don't and I literally I drink this
during the show and I don't get drowsy
anymore make a miracle for me
um
gamer Subs offers the healthiest and
best tasting alternative to energy
drinks and soda
GG
that's what they call a gamer sub
GG helps you stay focused during the day
without feeling like crap
they even have a caffeine-free option
for people that just want a taste to
drink
without the caffeine stop drinking sugar
guys sugar is bad for you and gamer sup
doesn't have any sugar in it enjoy
getting an energy boost to your day by
simply throwing Two Scoops into an iced
filler shaker cup or a cold water bottle
and Shake
it up it tastes great and it's a healthy
alternative than anything that has sugar
in it and it's probably cheaper than
anything you're buying to drink also
a lot of people use this product as a
gateway to a healthier lifestyle that's
true man if you're drinking soda dude
this is going to change your life you're
drinking like a full sugar soda
hmm
remember guys you can always use code H3
for a discount at checkout
and uh if you use the code H3 today you
will get 10 off your whole order
today and tomorrow and Friday yesterday
yeah always this will make that clear uh
Link in the description takes you to the
website and it also applies to the
discount code so gamersups
dot GG slash H3 we love you guys so much
thank you love Gamer sucks such a good
beverage
oh cheers
thank you phillydian you know Philly D's
a bigger fan of sup he loves it
apparently that's right
dude I can't believe I'm sweating
through my
you're prosthetic yeah
you have so many layers on you you know
like they chilled your hair down and
then put a whole thing on you I feel
comfortable though that's a weird part
but um yeah I think you're right Olivia
there's the Hat there's a lot of
moisture in that little debit though
okay let's get to Jimmy Lee Newsmax in
the waiting room oh all right let's
watch it first I didn't pick my nose
first of all guys just to clarify yeah
let's get ahead of that show me okay so
I have fake where does your nose
actually end it's mine real nose is like
way in here do you see from the side his
nose is so long right now he's clearing
an airway with the fake nose right I had
an edge right so the only way to itch
for my nose I guess it looks like a
super digging in there I just want to
point it again for gold that looks crazy
yeah it's like my whole [ __ ] finger
oh my God that's awesome
hey let me get them in here oh God no
I'm paying one bro I'm disgusting yeah
okay so let's watch this were you trying
to say something Amy
oh no nothing I'm just pointing out the
nose good thing just the bugs
yes so let's watch this and then we'll
have Jamie Lee calling we're gonna keep
it real tight with Jimmy don't get
worried I just want to check in
I want to know how this happened and if
you're Jimmy Lee hater just You're Gonna
Love This I Promise This is good for
them no I'm actually people know my
thoughts on Jimmy Lee I'm this is
[ __ ] hilarious we gotta talk to him
about this
yes so um Newsmax I guess you don't know
what they are you never heard of it they
used to be on television but they lost
their uh distribution deal I think
they're ah is that them or I think you
might be confusing with oam with the
other one but yeah I mean are they on TV
news Max uh is it still on cable they'll
plug there for Newsmax uh
yeah
uh yeah
um yeah it looks like they're still on
the air unless okay goes out of date but
yeah I think they're they're around so
Newsmax let me put it this way
they created a news station because Fox
News wasn't conservative enough
that's newsman I see yeah
here's Jimmy Lee
take out the trash please
ah
would you take out the trash this guy's
the luckiest guy Three Chicks what how
do you do I love that they're like here
he is making fun of a minority because
he looks like a janitor I'm assuming
that's a joke I mean that's right up
music that is the joke there it's hard
to tell there's layers but new so
there's an old-timey they hate
immigrants they hate you know the whole
shtick with the conservative stick so
they love this So Jamie found his
audience maybe he really did good I
think you're right take out the trash
please
can take out the trash the guy's about
to kill you dude this guy Three Chicks
how do you do this dude look listen your
talent outshines your head yeah it
really does you made a mistake well I
have a good divorce a lawyer he works
for the law firm do we cheat him in
house Gloria it's a lady from the
cemetery come here they reincorinated
her what like two years ago she's back I
thought you died I went to your viewing
now you're back
holy [ __ ] Canadian go home no one wants
you here that's good material
and that I think that's good that's a
good talking point they like that get
out of here yeah
nobody wants you here
I think you found his audience that's so
interesting yeah look at the headline
comedians comedian claims wokeness is
killing comedy oh my God
it's so true it's so true
goodness we had to do a little bit of
bleeping there but overall uh you may
know that man from uh many videos from
his outrageous online comedy skits and
Infamous call-ins to the H3 yeah Anthony
Benz Collins I cannot believe these
people are real sorry I got it back
though I just he's got like a Simpsons
news reporter voice
from uh many videos from his outrageous
online comedy skits Infamous Collins to
the H3
aka the I can't believe they talked
about us both Jimmy sent that yeah yeah
it's Jimmy's copy
Steve Ross you sent that yeah right
Jersey
the comedian viral YouTube personality
and a dentist by trade Jimmy welcome
thanks for coming on how'd you get into
comedy
first thanks
and soon because
um if I had to come into the studio I
couldn't get shot on the subway
it's tough out there crime is they love
that
hey thanks man all those minorities on
the subject tell me a crime am I right
man
the crime man
crime is crazy out there garage is crazy
out there folks
and there's a lot of obviously reporting
on that but there's a lot of folks in
the comedy world that kind of want to
stay away from talking about politics
I'm surprised he's not wearing his
glasses
let's ask him at the very least I'm
surprised that he didn't paint on the
hairline there I know dude I'm shocked
yeah he came humbled I think he did oh
maybe a little bit no he's he's got the
a little you know it's the Dracula
[ __ ] hey hello there you know he
cleaned it up it looks good it's
definitely died but but Jimmy I know
you're watching I think you look good
like this you don't need the whole step
you know what I mean
well today it's politically correct uh
I'm politely incorrect
um you know today you look to the left
they tell you look to the right you look
up they tell you look down you can't
tell one old guy you think two years ago
you weren't notified you have to be late
and polite back in the 80s and 90s when
I was a kid growing up I did the insults
the one-liners the zingers and um I feel
as I'm getting older I need to keep that
keep that [ __ ] just said zingers
did he just say he was a kid in the
night yeah that's what got me no he
didn't say that let me go back okay let
me go back let me go back
wait I was like yeah
only 90s kids remember hold on hold on
let me be like two years ago
you [ __ ] you have to be polite back in
the 80s and 90s when I was
he does say that the 80s and 90s when he
was a kid so I think Jimmy's probably
67 just taking a guess he's probably
about my dad's age I thought we figured
it out didn't we we did yeah didn't we
confirm his age at one point I don't
think we ever did he's like closer to
70. I think he was born like 1950.
like my dad and so he probably was a kid
no wait 1950 he'd be 72. okay so I think
it's about my dad's age this
[ __ ] grew up in the 50s 60s for
sure
he was 40 years old
[Applause]
[Music]
I think he might be right yeah right now
he's like
he was still growing up he's like in his
20s now right maturity wise right
growing up I did the insults the
one-liners the zingers and um I feel as
I'm getting older I need to keep that
keep that alive nobody's doing what I do
anymore so I do there's a reason for
that one I don't think anyone ever did
what he does
okay yeah so
um
I know I'm sorry just having a Halloween
moment this is how he got on the show
right he has two pictures of a trump
are they shocked
I'm just asking I don't know the only
thing shocked about it is his face doing
in it but I think they're real right
they look real with me okay fair enough
they I guess they Jimmy belongs to some
country club is he a Mar-A-Lago member I
know we gotta ask him it's um we gotta
get his ass in here in his hometown why
would Trump go to any club or any like
Golf Club but Mar-A-Lago either you know
we got to ask him well Jimmy's in Lucas
New York area so I'm in Jersey yeah I
guess that's true
he is Eli he's wearing the same shirt
as in that photo
that's interesting Sunday's best
the lucky shirt that's his nicest shirt
he owns
because he wears it when he meets Trump
he wears it on news map yeah it's a nice
shirt I'm surprised he's not doing that
iconic pose with him
God we're learning oh talk about him
yeah you're so right cam how many uh
wise guy I've never seen Don
Donnie with his hair like that wait
I have and it was only one time Jimmy
was there for that hold on
Donald Trump because I think yeah that
Trump was wearing that shirt in that
famous photo where his hair is all
slicked back okay
yeah this picture was posted six years
ago and I read it
so it's not three years ago people we've
been
we've been like that long yeah yeah
because we were in New York like six
seven years ago oh no and people people
are saying that I've never seen Donald
Trump's hair like that
people are saying too it is it's an
extremely rare trumpy but uh it kind of
looks better this seems to be better it
looks so much better yeah it looks good
no for sure
so this was this was the day so where
what was this if we could uh I actually
I think it may have been in because it
was posted six years ago that this was
more recent than that this was like two
years ago
we got a lot of questions for Jimmy it's
cool style yeah you call people out not
afraid to make fun of them uh which
we're in a very PC climate so I know
that that's kind of risky uh clearly no
fears of being canceled Jimmy I wanted
to ask you though about your views on
late night comedy uh why do you think
it's changed so much
well again I think people are just
politically correct or afraid to say
anything and um people are afraid so I'm
the guy that comes out with no filter
unhinged off the rails excuse me just
says what's on my mind and I think it
works because nobody nobody will do it
and uh the comedians I love how they
have like their whole media circus ready
like they pull up a picture
it's so awesome
so awesome so you got to talk some [ __ ]
on Kimmel because he's like obsessed
with getting on Kimmel no no he doesn't
okay he went there they don't interact
with the public like they used to back
in the old days I go out on the street
and I interact you know directly with
him in fact I got to tell you my TV show
is doing why they have a whole [ __ ]
reel of James Corden yeah it's awesome
the only one who knows about it you know
I mean the New York Times They gave me
last week two thumbs down an New York
Post they gave me one finger up gives
you an idea how I'm doing well you got
to be careful you know James Corden we
were talking he's like
well you know you got to be careful
let's bring it back to James Corden that
lib
let's smash the libs is like the
probably the least political out of all
of the late night guys I think they just
they go oh he's like shouldn't they be
mad at like Colbert
[Music]
or even or even camel camel like is more
of a lip like James Corden doesn't talk
about politics at all running the court
and story yeah I guess um treatment of
restaurant staff right
they turn it political they figure it
out that another comedian though but he
was Under Fire of how he treated
restaurant staff there and you know
what's so funny I had a flat Jimmy was
literally in the kitchen yeah of a deli
asking the yeah I was about to say
yeah Jimmy's like yeah that's crazy man
he's a real dick
he does say that watch coming out having
to apologize but it gets to this whole
point of having to pop yeah completely
different thing I don't know how a guy
goes in and does it he should order the
salad who could do that of course I mean
Shameless Jimmy Shameless he calls him
fat but like in a super unfunny way goes
in and does that he should have ordered
a salad no carbs I mean he's a big guy
oh and uh and not say anything but he
had to order 20 items and it became a
pain in the body and I'm steamed up
about it I gotta tell you Sean I'm steam
he's he's a real man
you're real mad about if there's one
thing that stands me up
it's the mysteryment of restaurants down
so perfect
we like to treat our restaurant uh
workers well oh yeah restaurant myself
um and I know that they they definitely
work hard real quick I wanted to touch
on this too if we could wait did I say
he owns a restaurant himself no he says
I used to work in a restaurant oh
I I heard I own a restaurant myself no
that's right well I I you know it's uh
it's we like to treat our restaurant uh
workers well uh I've worked in
restaurants
and I know that they they definitely
work hard real quick I wanted to touch
on this too if we could I know that you
met with President Trump former
president Trump there I saw some
pictures do you have a can you explain
that
well uh I've met Trump several times
he's actually so I got to tell you he's
a wonderful person I mean you asked him
he'll tell you he's not shy Donald Trump
and uh I I really think we need a guy
like him back in the White House oh
really yes we need people that are going
to allow us our freedom you know our
autonomy and the right to making fun
autonomy are you talking about like
like because he doesn't want to talk to
me why don't we ask him
he's going down in the same hole as Papa
John yeah oh that you know what I think
they get on really well Jimmy yeah oh
yeah right I think they'd be Besties
some decisions and I think we need them
all right maybe you got him to laugh at
a few jokes too does he have a good
sense of humor
he's a nice guy he really is he's a good
guy Donald Trump is 5 000 times funnier
than Jimmy Ray will ever be there we go
Jimmy Lee thanks thanks for coming on
appreciate the conversation for making
us laugh today
okay remember this this politics is a
very tricky business one week the cover
time and the next we Biden could be
doing time wow just lock him up he
edited that for the political hit hell
yeah well he knows the audience leave it
right there Jimmy Lee joining us live
yeah
I've been trying to try nothing
baby trying to bury those yeah I didn't
know if that was a reference to
something or if you just confused the
guy and he was playing along yeah
probably because he goes you look just
like you did in American Idol he's a
singer don't worry that man you still
look great I appreciate that that was a
long time ago Jimmy Lee doing against
the left maybe
you got the music playing the song uh it
was
we got the music playing oh we gotta go
all right let's bring him on man all
right let me bring them on right now
the whole segment's about cancel culture
and people being too sensitive and then
she's like oh you're gonna get me in
trouble let's play the music yeah that's
off you know what's funny I don't know
if they were one of the people that got
sued by uh right here's
what was the name of the voting company
Dominion
yeah
maybe because they got real tight-lipped
about that and that Lobster dropped
Jimmy
all right oh Jimmy Lee awakens news max
Fame
You Got Your Big Break there Jimmy
let me get it let me get situated this
is a new thing I just put on my uh okay
can you see me absolutely I can yeah so
uh so so uh I see you got yourself in a
dark room there
do you want it a little lighter
potentially lights on would be nice but
it's up to you I mean it's fine too
it's yeah I mean we want to sit in the
dark
Halloween episode survive it is a little
spooky that way for Halloween yeah okay
okay that's a good point that's a good
point so wait did you turn the lights on
or no I have the light in the other room
when I wanted to give you a little light
but I wanted it
to the darkness
Jimmy first of all nice to see you nice
to hear from you
oh thank you so much thank you yeah I
like yours still hey Jimmy I like your
outfit too Zing
it's the Jersey Outlaw so you guys doing
good okay yeah we're doing great uh so
listen how did tell me about this
Newsmax segment first of all how did it
come about how did you how did this
happen
um we just have a team of people now on
the back end and you know we have
people helping people you have a team of
how many people
we have two three publicity people for
social media people no you do not wait
what you have seven people working for
you
yes
stop it oh my God I mean you've seen his
Instagram like you pay on the cranking
it out how much does that cost you
just like you gotta pay your crew I
gotta pay my crew same thing same thing
wow
no I'm not making money no no no no come
on it's just like I mean the we see the
activity on socials it's been wild right
so the YouTube videos got way better and
the Instagrams and tick tocks so I have
you know Megan and Mason now I have
Olivia and Carly and I have a few PR
people and I have people in New York
that really helping me with media in New
York now we're getting a lot of activity
in New York we may be on another Big
Show I don't want to say anything wow
like a late night show like something
really big to be honest okay so so um I
want to ask you
uh
did they ask you to remove your glasses
uh because I noticed you have your
glasses on
um the producer wants me as a person not
in character so
I I had to you know wear my regular
shirt no glasses and I had to be a
normal person like I'm talking to you
normally yeah yeah we love that strategy
um
and so did you reach out to like how
does that work did you reach out to a
bunch of people and Newsmax is the only
one that answered it's almost like a
journey when you meet someone like I'll
give you an example right now we're
working what's in the box with um a new
company it's a YouTube series that's
coming out in a week or two where I open
things in a box and I have crazy
reactions I send Zach a picture of one
of the funny ones uh and and that comes
out in a couple weeks so you know it's a
new YouTube series that accompany New
York's developing okay interesting yeah
through there we meet people and people
know people in New York and one person
okay so so so okay so so do you watch
Newsmax are you are you a patron of
theirs no I'm not no where do you get
your news from just out of curiosity
well I work 14 16 hour days Ethan I
don't really have much time
so I'll be honest I watched the news at
night before I go to bed what channel
6 ABC oh the local news no no yeah I
watch CNN on weekends but honestly oh
CNN Jimmy if they they would have could
they would have given you the boot so
fast if they knew your ass was watching
CNN
so that's amazing
I was lucky to get news max and I want
to say thanks to Sean and Emma they're
Two Hosts and they were really nice to
me yeah yeah yeah yeah sweetheart just
nice people and I just really
appreciated them having one like I
appreciate uh you guys have me on and
they mentioned you crazy
to do that yeah that was nice appreciate
that shout out
um
what about those pictures of trump you
said you want Trump back in office was
that a just were you just playing to
your audience well I am a comedian I'm
not a politician and um I don't even
want to go there because I get in
trouble with that so we're gonna leave
that one go really well I'm a comedian
I'm not a politician and and you know
you know I know true well you don't
believe that at that you know Trump
yes of course we know Trump why is that
of course not of course at all I didn't
know that you know Trump
I've met Trump a lot of times does he
know your name what'd he see and say hey
Jimmy
probably not
you're asking me I'm not gonna lie yeah
I appreciate it so yeah I mean did you
so are you you voted for Trump probably
a lot in the last election yeah with all
of Joey okay that's interesting you
watch CNN by your Maga
what's that no I don't know I just
curious how this all happened but it's
very interesting Jimmy I'm happy for you
it's it's a team of people look I I look
up to you guys a lot I don't talk
seriously like this but I mean what hill
has accomplished with Teddy fresh that's
amazing what you guys did and what
you've done on your fan base and all the
work you've done and you have you have a
phenomenal team of people and um that
helped you to accomplish success and
I've done that in dental and I'm
starting to build that team and
entertainment and actually it's starting
starting to work somewhat I'm not saying
it's working as much as I want but it's
heading in the right direction I'll say
that to be honest and that's kind of
where we're going and we're going one
step at a time we're not rushing things
we're doing it kind of in order and
strategically you know so was there any
uh
after this interview you did on Newsmax
did you hear any chatter about this hot
new comedian Jimmy or anything like that
well I did see something up on Hollywood
Times uh today really up on that the
Hollywood Times
yes you can Google it uh-huh
and
um we have something in the works for
something big late like New York that we
heard from today
and um we don't want to say anything
until it happens because we don't just
like that my team doesn't want me to say
anything but there's things happening
and then that thing with James Corden
and balazar were reaching out to them to
try to do some fomo in that restaurant
and we haven't heard back from them yet
oh [ __ ] that's a shame you mentioned
well we mentioned it in the in Israel on
purpose and we're waiting to hear back
then because you're right I thought I
thought James Corden was wrong and you
know yeah yeah yeah yeah you would never
miss treat restaurant staff like him
right yeah never well I I I was a waiter
for four years through school and and
I'm extra nice to waiters and over tip
them because right yeah really hard jobs
yeah you can't be waiter you have to be
nice and uh listen we went to Felix we
did a fomo thing in New York a weekly I
did a promotional thing
and we had fomo there with the GM and
the owner okay
go to my Instagram uh panel Sam because
that's Sam on there no
everybody's here well I mean everyone's
here but oh all right go to my Instagram
and look about a week ago you'll see
some of the post-ops but you said we did
fomo with him I don't know what does
that mean
when I see firmware if I'm in a
restaurant I see there's fomo or or or
at Adidas there's excitement and there's
fans and there's a lot of activity
almost a term in entertainment for fear
missing out so you know
so
you had a fear of missing out with them
but you're not missing out you're in the
action
you're missing out if you can create
excitement Charisma and a lot of uh
entertainment style buzz you know where
a person wants to see you because they
have fear of missing out
but you wouldn't right right you okay
you would be causing other people to
have fomo you know you Ethan course fomo
you know people have to watch your show
so they don't miss things
you know when I I make a whole thing and
I start taking pictures and I I went up
to a table because two of the people
recognize guys you're on TV and they all
got excited and and and and that's up on
the Instagram they're creating that
excitement where there's fans and and
you know we create that buzz which is
basically what you guys we need the fomo
more fomo Mo Problems perhaps
here it is you've got it how'd you get
that free Adidas tracksuit by the way
because because I did an event for them
they asked me to go in last Saturday
that's a real reason we went in for who
[Laughter]
hey what did you do for Adidas
they just wanted me as a social media
influencer to go in and promote their
wish so there was a bunch of people it's
like I put on about three and a half
bits Jimmy respectfully there's no
chance that that's happened
it did happen because that's that was
why we went the Felix thing was off the
cup the Adidas thing is because I know
the manager that works there I know the
girl oh so it wasn't like Adidas
corporate it was like Adidas
oh okay okay that I believe and then so
you were doing schtick at Adidas so you
got to create the fomo and then they get
excited people around they want to take
pictures like I did my Fanfare and then
at the end they gave me a free sweatsuit
that's all it wasn't anything from a
corporate now how many people showed up
to the Adidas store well it's the people
that are there they didn't come it
wasn't a Fanfare announcement they just
basically oh no family
are you just harassing the customers who
are there shopping
pretty fomo
[Laughter]
that track
it's 200 oh my God
he said can I have this switch because
yeah you helped us out you promoted
whatever you want I'll take images no I
didn't ask for the whole story
yeah so
um my my team a couple people took a
picture we put it up on social media if
you look at the edge let me see I want
to see that it's in the chat yeah it's
it's there black lives matter they put a
thing up because Kanye West had problems
with Adidas a week ago you'll see it
it's in indeed I hadn't heard about that
there you are that's [ __ ] original no
no that's not the one that's not it oh
go to go what's this one from Jimmy
that's in Las Vegas that's just when I
was in the storm you're just a fan of
Adidas and you wanted to post yeah yeah
that was nothing go to the one a week
ago in New York from one week ago you'll
see me wearing a yellow sweat suit go
back on the in the Instagram to about it
can you just post me his uh Instagram
guys yeah
yeah one sec there Jim Jimbo
there you go
Ethan who are you supposed to be I like
yours oh the Penguin from Batman
yeah
very cool thank you so let's see
um Bruce Jenner oh this one was really
good by the way I like this one watch
this watch this one guys
really yeah and what's up
That's a classic one that's probably
about three four years ago yeah and
what's the joke here well take a look at
his stomach it wasn't a hard one to
figure out really
but you say really so so you're
basically just being like seriously
you're this fat and disgusting
well it's a B's idea to be honest don't
blame me
it's a good joke Man Jimmy uh
Jimmy what do you think about Amy's
costume I'm just curious
trick or treat Charlie yeah the trigger
see Charlie that's right it wasn't trick
or treat Ahmed I'll take it
hey can you explain this post to me
Jimmy we out here [ __ ] drip
got to ask my social media people I
don't do them wait do you do you do you
like look at the post before it's posted
or do you just let it do it okay
sometimes
I think that's promoting my my
um have my um here but but to give you
an idea how good my gears don't I'm the
only one that's buying it right now yeah
I've always been doing
that's surprising man
I'm surprised by that yeah oh is that
the yellow suit oh here it is is it this
one
no I linked it for you oh no go go
further down
can you unpack this one for me
I didn't do it it says Abby Lee Miller
I don't even know what it is it's fomo
wait so you don't you don't you don't
know what it is but you can still posted
[Laughter]
okay what about this one nobody's
perfect especially you
go to the one that says black lives
matter the yellow sweatshirt that's the
one they gave me dude you post so much I
can't find it you have like 20 plus a
day go back okay what the [ __ ] is this
what's that
well [ __ ] juice
again
[Laughter]
this is the kid from Breaking Bad
you like that yeah
did like that what the hell dude oh God
that's really funny go further back
Ethan oh good God how much do you post
well they're been posting too much one
of my New York people said oh they're
coming into now in there there it is
there it is wait before I open this I
wanna look like a yellow switch got it
right there is it this one right here
no well that's the TMZ one they picked
up on from uh that's when the fans
recognized me it feels fans these are
children Jimmy
oh they recognize
thank you for me no no no no you're
taking that picture with them why are
you taking pictures with kids Jimmy all
right I went in to say thanks to the
manager they go oh my God it's Jimmy Lee
from H3 so I said gosh you're on TV and
I went in the front and my photographer
took a picture that's how that happened
right the kid's fat or ugly did you
no they said you're Jimmy Lee from H3 I
said yeah gear on TV
go to the one where I have the yellow
sweatshirt says this one right here
Jimmy Lee fomo at the frescon New York
oh that's at the restaurant Fresco
that's where we enter Fresco's oh wait a
minute Ethan that's we're on lunch with
you and Hilda okay okay
yeah what about this one Jimmy can we
get much higher
what's this one
go
up right there that's it you got it
right there
black lives matter is it the one on the
red
yellow
[Laughter]
sorry I just I'm not good with that I
can't stop stop stop BLM I'm looking
down here oh be a lamb
Jimmy what the [ __ ] is this
what
Bingo hey it's me hey it's me Big Jimmy
guess what I had for breakfast the whole
Buffet Bingo oh my god
oh boy all right let me find this yellow
one I don't know what you're talking
about stop stop
I don't see it I don't know what you're
talking about
this one here I mean this one is yeah
under it now
that's James
they gave me
why does it say BLM bruh black lives
matter I know what like it just is there
no look at the top oh I don't give a
[ __ ] what yay said black lives matter
for life forever
for sure hey you're out here looking
like a can of sprite dude in that Adidas
you live out there looking like a can of
sprite tell me that color's not cool do
you like the yellow or not I like
interesting colors
I mean you look like lemon lime yeah all
right
Jimmy
you're on embargo technically
so I guess it's a good time to wrap it
up but it's been nice to hear from you
nice to see you're doing well
um do you think all lives matter Jimmy
I think everybody all can decide with my
comment I think everybody matters black
white Spanish so you said White lives
matter
everybody knows so would you say so
which one would you say is more accurate
all lives matter or black lives matter
all lives now
[Music]
lives matter
ladies and gentlemen we got him we got
him
no you're right all lives do matter
absolutely for sure and would you say
would you say that crime
would you say that
crime happens when people as a function
of like your class right so if you're
more poor you're more likely to commit
crime
if you think it's some ending quality of
people that they're just bad people and
they commit crime
no I think it's the person because what
about the wealthy people that do
white-collar crime
fomo baby I also saw one that was like a
big burning cross I didn't know if that
was appropriate or not you might want to
just ask your team about that you might
want a little more oversight into these
because if you're just posting stuff
then there's no oversight I think what I
may do is post them myself and have them
send me because yeah mentioning about
there was one because there's one if you
go back it's like clan members and
they're burning the cross I was like
this is weird Jimmy but you're not like
a member of the clan are you no okay so
you should erase that one so I'm going
to have to I'll take the channel over
and send me stuff and I'll figure it out
I'm gonna work it the way I was before
they've had my channel so obviously uh
let me just go wait what is this one
Jimmy
what does it say wanted work with me the
Jersey Outlet does not condone the
actions of The Wanted domestic
terrorists Ezra Miller and hereby offers
his name for the recast of Barry Allen
AKA The Flash the Jersey Outlaw as the
flash hashtag that could probably be one
of my fans that doesn't look like my
social media people now
[Music]
I don't know what that is
did you sit along with the world Towers
uh burning yeah the 911 whether the
World Trade Center tasteless that you
posted that on 911 Jimmy
say it again you posted a picture of not
of the World Trade Center on fire and
and it was you being like work with me
and I on 911 and I thought that was
inappropriate
I did that I was on your Instagram
somebody did
well I didn't do that somebody somebody
that it wasn't me I mean it's your name
well what about what about the one with
all like the euthanized dogs and you're
like work with me work with me that one
was crazy yeah did you put seriously
posted a picture of Auschwitz that said
Jimmy where is flame [ __ ]
it's on your page all right well then I
have to make a phone call I have girls
doing it I let them have the channel I'm
afraid that might be white supremacists
you might want to check on it right all
right listen thank you Jimmy
when is this show go on it's not live
tonight on Monday on Monday okay cool I
appreciate that of course and um just so
you know there's a chance we may be
coming out if there if there's a a TV or
big thing out there I'll give Zach a
heads up if we come out and uh love to
see you guys if we come out that'd be
great love it okay and I appreciate the
love and I love you all you guys thank
you
um just to let you know by the way Jimmy
I know it's been a long time since Pearl
Harbor Pearl Harbor happened yeah but
the edit of you on the uh
the deck of the Arizona
yeah and then there's a kamikaze pilot
flying in saying bingo
oh is that another post yeah all right
it's pretty [ __ ] up picture of Jimmy
Eric on the Cozy playing coin
[Music]
that was [ __ ] up
um
happy Halloween no happy halloweener
oh like your last name and like a like a
penis
yeah and by the way Jimmy joking about
Katrina is kind of a on the line
like Hurricane Katrina it's just a
tragedy and we shouldn't really poke fun
at it like that post of you on a boat
swimming in the flood water and they're
trying to get onto the boat and you're
kicking them off and like there's no
room sorry whatever this is work with me
well don't joke about that stuff
are they poached that he's one up
because they're funny or do you want
them down well I mean they're funny but
it's just I I worry that it's going to
get you in a lot of trouble like Newsmax
doesn't give a [ __ ] obviously but you
know if you're trying to go mainstream
this is the kind of stuff that could
sink your career absolutely
then I have to make a phone call yeah
yeah you got to scrub you gotta scrub
cool I'll do that hey by the way
you posted
face
on the guy shooting hey rambling
what was it what was it you were
assassinating Abraham Lincoln you were
John Wilkes Booth your face was
photoshopped he said you said and you
were shouting Bingo as the gun rock it
was like I've never seen that depiction
before but there's actually like brain
matter like flying out is that on
Instagram yes yes
you're telling me a lot of posts I don't
even know about and Abe's wearing a
Jimmy wear shirt yeah I mean it's good
promotion but
right Abe Lincoln yeah
my goodness
oh real quick did you guys see some of
the Comic-Con stuff from two weeks back
yeah oh you're on New York Comic Con
right we went it was really good A lot
of people recognized me thanks to you
guys
a lot a lot of H3 fans a lot of people I
would say 50 people knew me there no way
that's awesome really yeah so I love you
guys for yeah and just just to be clear
that people are really sensitive about
World War II and so
during D-Day or I think it was or
they're all lifting the flag oh uh Iwo
Jima Iwo Jima yeah you put your face on
like all five of the guys yeah and it's
like kind of if people think that's
still it's a little disrespectful yeah
on Veterans Day it's just a little did
you serve in the military
yeah are you a veteran
no I'm not that old
right yeah
I'm 75 years old oh I just remembered
another one
you were flying the plane that dropped
the bomb over Hiroshima oh I wasn't yeah
the Enola Gay it says it on the side
it literally says the Enola Gay on the
side it's the plane that dropped the
bomb it's [ __ ] up and you're like and
I'll show you something else that's gay
that's what you're saying and then
you're dropping the bomb on a bunch of
Japanese people and then below it it
says you're if you're not gay you're on
the waiting list right oh that's my joke
I didn't put that I didn't put it up the
girls well you just said it's your joke
absolutely I mean
but I didn't put that your page is your
joke it sounds like maybe all those
innocence yeah
yeah children women or dying painfully
from radiation poisoning over weeks even
months that's [ __ ] up people still
having birth Jimmy people are still
having birth defects from that
I got you yeah okay
all right you take care all right all
right I love you guys keep an eye okay
keep an eye on that Instagram page but
it's that nice to catch up okay buddy
all right all right we love you happy
Halloween YouTube I come out of the
wiener happy halloweener happy Halloween
all right bye guys love you take care
love you too Jimmy all right be good be
good I will you too all right
foreign
I can't believe it's not banned fomo
yeah felma
that was just so disgusting I mean I
love Jimmy but that's it
way too far yeah yeah yeah yeah like why
would you put your face on Jeffrey
Dahmer
Jeffrey dahmers Jeffrey Jeffy Dahmer
yeah
this is my hero that's just crazy yeah
inappropriate yeah yeah weird
anyway the one with yeah I have to
always Jimmy ends up taking way more too
much time well what about the one he
posted of where he's like Lee Harvey
Oswald at the top of the Texas Book
Depository and I mean he's shooting JFK
he's a bingo
they're all insane but I don't think
anything will pop Walt Jr for me
personally
yeah
I hope we didn't
I hope we verifies that any of this is
real before he fires all yes I was just
thinking that okay
hey uh I just wanted to ask did you post
a picture of me as Adolf Hitler
[Laughter]
bingo bingo all right we are at an hour
almost 40 already all right and uh I
know we have a little bit of limited
time today so if there's anything you
really want to get to now is the time
I gotta get to these
oh yeah the candy it's Halloween we
can't skip out on the candy tearless
um all right let me Focus Jimmy God damn
it you always takes way so much
dentist is gone now it's time for some
candy baby right for real here's a
Jordan Peterson clip I can't help myself
well the question did that happen
begs the question wait we watched this
already
I think so we did that's the one where
it's like and what does what mean if if
what if to figure out what what if is
what matters what really matters is what
matters what's matter
what it's that same clip I think so but
the question did that happen
begs the question what do you mean by
happen because when you are dealing with
fundamental realities and you posed a
question you have to understand that the
reality of the concepts of your question
when you're digging that deep are just
as questionable
uh
question did
the concepts of your question
when you're digging that deep are just
as questionable about I'm sorry this is
a different one he did it again yeah he
did it again he does it all the time
like this is just like I don't really
know what to say to sound smart here so
I'm just gonna drill down if you want to
understand the question yeah you have to
first question what does question mean
first of all the letter Q where does
that come from beauty we have to define
the letter Q before we can answer the
question
it's a letter of the alphabet
what is the alphabet
as what you're questioning you know it's
a question
what do you do you believe in God and I
think okay there's a couple of mysteries
in that question what do you mean do
that's a couple of mysteries what do you
mean by dude
wait I don't know how what how many
definitions he could be working with
them wait till his next line is this his
comedy material I wonder honestly it is
very good what do you mean you what do
you mean believe and what do you mean
God and you say as the questioner well
we already know what all those things
mean except belief in God and I think no
if we're going to get down to the
fundamental brass by the way there's
something incredibly ironic about this
guy is Mr there's two genders
don't overthink it right right and then
this [ __ ] he goes dude answer
the question of do I believe in God we
have to Define what it's due what is how
oh my god dude
it's taxed we don't really know what any
of those things mean well I've never
seen someone try to avoid answering a
question more than this I'm trying to
make a point just answer the [ __ ]
question do you believe in God or not no
it's not that simple no you first we
need there's a couple of mysteries in
that question first of all what do you
mean by do what do you mean by you no
and who what do you believe
what do you mean by do [ __ ] are
you serious
it's like uh wasn't there a joke about
that there was a big trial where he says
the defense attorney what are you
thinking of uh Bill Clinton during the
Monaco yesterday investigation what is
what is the definition of is
it's giving me that depends on or he
says like it depends on the definition
of what the word is is did you have an
affair or something or is it true that
you had an affair he goes well it
depends what's the definition of is
[Laughter]
it's giving me that
okay there it is okay moving on we love
you I love it Jordan and Jimmy do you
know that it's freezing here well no
because like I'm shaking like layers
my face is under like a whole layer of
blubber do you want me to turn it off
for a second or is that you can turn it
down yes I don't I mean I don't want you
to melt oh I'm comfortable now if I get
hot okay yeah let's turn it off for a
second I'll let you know
Wally oh man there's so much good [ __ ]
there's too much good [ __ ] and we better
get to this [ __ ] candy too wait
Jimmy's calling you again what does he
say he's thing he's like that's not my
Instagram that's a different one
oh [ __ ] he's worried about it now yeah
he's worried just tell him we're [ __ ]
with him and he's an idiot for believing
us
just tell him it's an old-timey joke
tell him it's an old-timey joke say that
yeah all right maybe not the idiot part
yeah well my point I was trying to make
a point which is that right he can't
just let people post all this crazy [ __ ]
on his page yeah no the top insane [ __ ]
right
I mean it's hilarious but it's a little
wild you said so you scared the [ __ ] out
of me
and then he said guck [ __ ] because I
never did that
yeah yeah he's good cool he has some
kind of a person that deletes posts
sometimes because I replied on one and
said bruh and then someone dm'd me on
his team saying sorry about that I
removed the post
[Laughter]
[Music]
Handler that removes toxic Force do you
think he's paying a lot of money on all
this marketing people I do from
experience and I know that we didn't
continue with PR because it's really
expensive yeah if he's with the legit PR
firm yes
taking his money dude he's like I'm on
Newsmax they got him on on the show I
mean they did get him on Newsmax yeah he
told me they're he's paying him a
shitload yeah so he always always I'll
give you guys an idea like it's anywhere
between
seven and twenty five thousand dollars a
month
yep also seven is for like shoestring
bottom of the barrel [ __ ] oh damn I
looked up
um Jimmy Lee Hollywood Times when he
said that he was in it he's been in the
Hollywood times at least like 10 times
yeah really that's why I kind of circle
I was like the Hollywood times because
uh yeah look it up Dan well I'm pretty
sure it's you know who owns the
Hollywood Times you know who owns the
Holly times the PR Company that's just
taken his money right I was going to say
I'm pretty sure
you can just pay to be in that magazine
he needs to hook me up
all right I got to move on dude I'm
running low until yeah yeah like 30
minutes before we need to ah all right I
gotta well I have so much [ __ ] what do
we do because I have the whole response
to all the drama I gotta talk about that
yes I want it's Halloween
no you have a guest on Wednesday
who
I heard it's Connor you could talk about
it on see you next Tuesday
yeah that's a great place to talk about
yeah
[Music]
common ideas man I'm full I wanted to do
it today or there's so much good stuff I
have liquid am I coming out of my ear
bro it's so weird we gotta do the tier
list the candy tier list the audience
demands it yeah it is
this whole time
lunch time lunch time
[ __ ] okay so then I guess everyone who
wants to hear me talk is that lame I
mean there's so much good stuff Ben
Shapiro responded to me a few times she
tweeted at me bench Barrel retweeted
keemstar my goodness it was so good uh
uh and then and this is and then I guess
there's not that much to it the Andrew
Tate and Steve will do it talk about how
much they hate me is amazing
it's just so good it's short it's short
it's short let's watch that real fast
okay it's short and it's so good that's
not even directly related to the band
that's what I'm being mad but okay well
he mentions it right right whatever so
both of these idiots are banned on like
all socials so now they're on Rumble
having their own uh special show here
together but here it is the rest of my
life because I've changed many lives and
you want to cancel me and then there's
someone like like I know I like I'm
gonna say I [ __ ] hate Ethan Klein I
[ __ ] hate him no I'm saying about him
but I'm saying but like like my like
it's not biased but I'm saying like this
is facts dude he [ __ ] hates me it
really does
well it's mutual so that's okay I don't
hate him why not have sex with Don
because he hate takes energy I feel like
I don't hate him at all I mean I think
it takes a lot for us to really hate
somebody honestly I don't even know him
I don't know anything about him yeah I
just honestly I just really thought that
jerking off the dog thing was funny
can I put this in a ponytail be kind of
fire then you become Benjamin Franklin
again
oh my God
[Laughter]
I actually I don't know how to not look
like Benjamin Franklin now
[Laughter]
well they are cutting I mean there's
they've got a similar
Vibe yeah why do you look like zombie
Ben Franklin the more I look at myself
the more I look like Ben Frank
anyway yeah so um
yeah I don't hate him
you know all right
I mean I don't think about him hate is
like really strong yeah I don't think
about Steve will do it at all ever yeah
right I guess it's true or like you go
cow style the only time I think most
people do is when I see the dogs on
their back could have sex with Donnie
Steve would have a good old time here
with this boy oh God I'd be like man I
wish Steve was here Jeffrey dahmers
Shredder would be like I wish steam was
here anyway
Martin Bradley Bradley Martin is
confirmed he's confirmed yeah
[Music]
so that'd actually be fun I'm looking
forward to that
I don't know how it's gonna go because
he's really good friends with Steve and
I don't want any weird I really do like
Brad I said if there was
whatever yeah I'm gonna skip the part
where he says what I said because I'm a
nun now but you guys don't know what I
said gets suspended for one week but
someone that spends 250 000 to 500 000 a
week helping
people that have [ __ ] up lives have
kids oh is that why they feed them have
all this and
helping people well it's weird that it
yeah I mean that if that's what he was
banned for for giving a quarter of a
million dollars to needy people that's
very strange that is connected that's
how he got the money
I also want to point out that you didn't
post anything on a different Channel
while you were banned just saying oh did
he do that well wasn't that the reason
why the ultimate decision was because he
did that no he posted gambling videos on
his second Channel yeah but after they
had been removed from his primary
Channel and then he reposted removed
content idiot bro how are you gonna sit
there and play victim you did like the
dumbest [ __ ] thing it's literally
that Meme where you put the stick in the
bikes yeah exactly why did YouTube do
this YouTube did this
foreign
told a joke and he was only suspended
for a week their logic is weird it's
like are you wanting more punitive
measures by YouTube is that what they're
advocating for I think he's just
to be charitable to him he's just saying
look at the double standard he's saying
I got banned for this but this guy only
gets suspended for a week related I mean
I agree and also he's not being honest
when he says what he was suspended for
so it's not really a fair argument if
we're being a good guy
but on YouTube it doesn't want me to
feed home I'm just too good of a person
yeah you can keep doing that
right you don't have to make you don't
even have to film it and put it online
bro you can actually just do it changing
their lives they they spend all their
money
I'll tell you why because Ethan Klein
and it is it's not personal I love this
objectively this is straight the count
the evil uh access to people are that
League of villains or whatever it's
awesome Legion of Doom this is Andrew
Tate and Steve will do a [ __ ] crying
about me on Rumble it doesn't get better
than this folks Donnie
if only Donnie were here though
if only if Donnie could talk let me tell
you
it's not personal he's objectively a
dislikable person he's objectively an
evil horrible Savage
okay you could say detestable I'll
accept that maybe but to say I'm
objectively evil is a little bit wild
bro come on both of these men called me
ugly right I was like out of nowhere
they're probably both just sitting there
crying together about how ugly I am is
she so ugly
ER you look foreign
that's not really how it works that's
why you're objectively Evil by the way
yeah that's the game
this is why Alpha men are so it just
sucks because you're in a culture right
where you have Andrew take your hero
telling you basically signaling to you
that antidepressants just for weak
people and uh miserable
beings [ __ ] yes and it's just not it's
just sad yeah it's just sad
and he spreads hatred and when you
spread hatred out into the universe when
you spread hate you manage to divide the
populace when you apocalypse is divided
they can be controlled see that's what
he's talking that is exactly what here
Tate did yes the guy who spread so much
hate yeah that he's gonna talk about us
spreading hate it's it's just like I I
truly believe that he has messed up like
a full age group for seems like this I
agree like I imagine that yeah that's
whenever we talk to other people who are
around like kids in school age all those
kids know about him and look up to him
definitely done more damage to the
populace yeah the popular population I'm
a man of God yeah those poor girls yeah
but um also sorry to say this but am I
picking up on a little bit of Jewish
conspiracy theory here hatred and when
you spread hatred out into the universe
when you spread hate you manage to
divide the population when you a
populist is divided they can be
controlled oh he says I'm trying to
control the populace oh yeah yeah
George Soros yeah which is funny because
in the beginning they accused me of
anti-semitism
they go he's so anti-semitic he said
this and then Andrew Tate's like he is
uh trying to control the populations I
could literally say anti-semitic [ __ ]
and they can't drop me
not true you were starting to have one
the absolute opposite you were uniting
people you had Mass influence and when
you have large amounts of influence and
they don't own your soul and mind and
you're also genuinely bringing
positivity to people it's positive
people that resist all right save it for
the for the [ __ ] for the jury or yes
tell it to the judge anyway I thought
that was fun oh [ __ ] okay I guess we're
gonna have to so if you guys want to
hear me talk about Ben Shapiro and the
whole cancellation stuff I got but the
people here have a right to hear it what
is this
with peace and love how am I doing what
is what are you going to say everybody
saw what happened we got suspended for a
week and we're back
it is what it is it isn't what it ain't
what it is are we doing the candy or are
we not because the clock is the clock is
ticking and it's freaking Halloween man
hey who's this
check this out
Brent Franklin or penguin
same here but yo that's a really
ambitious person honestly that's a hard
haircut to pull off that dude's hairline
goes into the back of his head he has an
inverse hairline he has a headband of
balls appreciate that though I'm also
seeing in you Uncle Fester growing his
hair back after Brian there is yeah yeah
for sure in the eyes I had the same yeah
all right let's let's go to the tier
list we you know what I mean we we have
to leave in about 30 minutes we have
we're having a party a Halloween party
for Teddy fresh from the podcast some
friends and family so we don't we don't
be late to that so uh let's just do this
then
um
so yeah if you want to watch uh members
I love you so much by the way I was
afraid a lot of members were gonna bail
from the suspension either because you
know we couldn't do for a week or people
were disappointing me whatever I'll tell
you what we'd lost almost almost none
oh yeah and I [ __ ] love you guys oh
yeah this cord was popping off everyone
was really supportive of each other
that's awesome yeah
well I'm happy to be back I really did
did you see I really did miss
I felt like such a [ __ ] idiot because
God it just sucks missing
uh the show for a week and like just for
a stupid-ass joke of course Hassan was
right
you know and who else
Daniel
what did Dan say he just said I couldn't
ship ooh what else did he say
he said stop doesn't matter ten times
man who else is right oh wait yeah yeah
yeah that was right of course yes but
but he's always telling me to stop so
it's hard to honestly it's hard to know
when to take it seriously
foreign
right that's what I used to tell my dad
I mean am I always telling you to stop
I mean you're the you're the Chief
Architect of stop right I feel like I've
only been forceful about it a few times
and most of those times have been times
that we got suspended yeah yeah I mean
you have a really good batting average
Ben deserves a little like one clean
then was right Dan was right I mean I
always say that Dan is always yeah no
Ethan has not been in denial about that
I'm not in denial thank you Dan let me
get my thoughts together here I think
the audience needs to be more
understanding what never mind no I mean
but you know sometimes I see those
comments like Dan's trying why is Dan
trying to control the show well I hope
you guys enjoy them off because oh don't
try to save it I don't see that they do
that to me too and then they're like so
controlling and it's like well I don't
know you guys are kind of trying to make
sure that somebody's got a
counterbalance and listen Ethan is it we
get it do you you are an edgy comedian
and you gotta you gotta toe the line and
that's where a lot that's why people
like you but yeah I mean
can't control my goo
but to counterbalance that you need you
need an Ela or if she's not here a Dan
to be like this easy tiger easy tiger if
you guys are blaming them I mean that
that's insane obviously
they're acting in the benefit of the
show always it's not a majority
obviously no yeah a few annoying
comments but like I just felt obviously
I realized I was I wasn't
first of all I'll just be honest what I
said was like obviously like
I'm not let's just say this I'm not
surprised YouTube you know suspended us
yeah it gave me a strike yeah that being
said it's like um
I mean I I think the joke was like you
know when the but like Hassan was saying
you give them the opportunity yes to
just take the clip and go and it's like
crazy how far people that's all it takes
you know it's insane how far people and
they don't care like the no the the
context it matters zilch to them yeah
yeah
so Hassan was telling me that on our
four bit we had to remove our leftovers
episode I felt like a [ __ ] idiot for
that too because the song came here yeah
you know we po we filmed the whole
episode that I thought was really good
episode then we had to [ __ ] erase it
because I said some stuff that was maybe
I don't know too close and it was right
after the we got word that we got
suspended so we just made the decision
to remove it yeah
um so obviously you know I would I was
just careless just stupid I don't know
I mean I don't I don't feel I don't
personally feel like
I mean look [ __ ] Ben Shapiro the guy I
mean like Uncle Tov I think I like that
expression for him and I think we I
think he really is an uncle Tov you get
that yeah
do you know what that means so if it's
good
dish Tova man's name and
what I was saying I'd never met a
[ __ ] Dove I don't know where
the Tove came from somebody was saying
in chapter is like yeah in Hebrew isn't
it isn't it
yeah yeah Uncle tuvia well you know what
uncle and Uncle Tom is oh Uncle Tom yes
I do yes so he's like an Uncle Tom for
the Jewish people he's uncle tuvia
or I don't know if you have a better uh
yeah two of you yeah Uncle tuvia that's
pretty good
um so you know I mean [ __ ] him and [ __ ]
all these people I mean I just get so
angry sometimes thinking about all this
[ __ ] it's just these people are just so
[ __ ] up and they're so bad faith and
it's just it's just hard man it just get
so [ __ ] angry sometimes and obviously
I
I just need to stop with the wishing
death on people right I mean ultimately
even as a joke because now we've seen it
twice that people have taken a five
second clip and blasted on Twitter and
it doesn't matter what you say before
and after that it really doesn't it
genuinely doesn't we live in a world
where the sound bite is all that matters
and you gave them you gave your enemies
a gift well they're all provocateurs
they don't give a [ __ ] right and when I
said that I was I a bunch of like white
supremacists convinced YouTube to
suspend me I meant that I mean these
people are like the fringes the people
who are tweeting it out and spreading it
on social media are the fringiest
right-wing provocateurs and pieces of
[ __ ] you can imagine and I guarantee you
many of them are just straight up
anti-semitic and so it you know it's
like but there it is you give them the
ammunition and they load it up and
that's how it is you know what I mean
yes indeed so obviously I got to be a
little bit smarter about what I say on
the show and and I'm and I'm gonna be
doing that and uh with peace and love no
more when pushing death on people thank
you thank you peace and love thank you
uncle tovia is there there's got to be a
better name than that I feel like
an uncle tovia it's pretty good though
I think the uncle Tov kind of makes
sense Uncle Tov oh so you like it when I
say it like that because of the Tom Tove
so you like Uncle Tove
yeah but I mean it's not a name so it
doesn't make sense then okay
Uncle tovia yeah so you know I I do
apologize honestly to everybody who uh
who you know
enjoys or depends some of you all on the
show every week to get you through the
week I've I have shows like that you
know some and it's like when they don't
show up it's just such a bummer a lot of
you guys pay you're paying members so I
fail you when I do that and that's why I
felt the most bad and uh missing a whole
week of shows just really really sucks
you know
but
we're back and I'm a nun that's right
odd Peace and Love An Angel I'm a
neighbor Jesus
I'm an Evangelical
and I say
fish ain't the only thing I eat for oh
boy if you got the blood of the young
you bring them to me
Hallelujah
you bring them to me
they look [ __ ] terrific
amen and I wanna say to all you out here
bring me your young
you're awake
your dick crapping
and I will take care of them this is the
blood of God I will make sure they are
seeing
oh Jesus
I will make sure they eat and drink of
the body of Christ
and I shall take care of your kids over
the whole summer vacation
I will lead them and
prayer
and overnight camping
I can't do that
I will share a sleeping bag with your
liver okay all right
[Music]
and you shall know my name
I am a man of God
please donate to my church at www
I [ __ ] kids.com
and furthermore
amen all right head on over to I [ __ ]
his dog can't be tearless slash slot
bucket think of these candies here's
yourself all right wow we got all these
beautiful cameras all right all right
yes okay so here is our list from last
year
more like three years ago our last list
this is what was done internally by the
crew uh which at the time was me Ila Dan
Ian and Zach I think I think so that's
right yeah and so this was um
this was our list now what's interesting
here
obviously have new crew members but I
don't want to go over the whole list
that'd be redundant so what we've done
is that first we've added
new candies
do I have the the thing or you guys have
the
the tier list
it's in there
okay well here's the this is the candies
that are being modified
new entries and some
are being hotly contested
uh yeah so rather than relitigate
everything we just we pulled internally
and then any of them that changed
significantly which we defined as
two tiers or more like if it moved up
two tiers or down two tiers or more okay
then it's worth readdressing here anyway
you guys did the least the the audience
we did also uh put it out to the
audience and the audience result was uh
pretty wild the one you're looking for
is down here at the bottom Ethan here I
just highlighted that's what I just
opened I need don't don't we have like a
changeable
file where we can drag them around and
oh no it's just a screenshot we can grab
that rank them
they are ranked that's what I'm saying
these Yeah by who By Us by everybody on
the crew I didn't vote oh so it already
happened it already happened okay wait I
didn't vote you said you didn't want to
we know what we know what you like come
on the original tier list was practical
you just put nerds at a that's inside oh
yeah
all right so let's look over this okay
and let's let's discuss so these these
were ones that were changed okay we have
new entries uh so nerds was at d right
y'all really moved it up to a nurse can
I have some I always felt like the nerd
slander what was the biggest mistake
yeah that was one of the biggest
mistakes like nerds is such a personal
you guys all love nerds like Universal
loves I rated s oh you did so you know
these are averages so some people
probably rated at C ish or whatever but
clearly D was too low
have you ever had the the Clusters or
the nerd ropes they're so good nerd's
rope is Bomb I mean I don't know they're
fine it's not an eight here I mean
that's a little psycho
sorry
you guys [ __ ] move peanut butter M
M's from s to b what the [ __ ] yeah
they're you overrate those really what
yeah rated those low yeah which one are
you
I pick up cowards I don't remember off
the top of my head I probably rated it B
like I don't hate them but they're not s
they're not us
nobody gonna speak up
anybody who did it
cowards I gave it an ass tear I also
gave it us we didn't ask
what what is it at
uh it's now at B it was s you know what
I think I gave it a d there you go what
there it is
looking kind of guilty over here too
maybe they're so good you know what do
you got a peanut allergy or some [ __ ]
cam what do you hate up against a peanut
butter M&M I just don't like chocolate
most of the chocolate ones I gave lower
score you don't like chocolate so you
give it a d I'm gonna listen to that how
is that this is [ __ ] you asked me my
opinion and I gave it that's that's just
this is why we have this is why we have
Representatives this is why democracy
doesn't work I feel cute
democracy died
I think where it landed is fair because
there's some people it's a love it or
hate it kind of candy no it's not I
think it is I think it's evidenced by
where it landed all right well we're
gonna open the
we're all gonna get a real dose of
reality when we open the audience vote
the audience is full of absolute
Psychopaths based off of their candy
tear list hater okay by the way there's
50 000 people voted on it so you're
going against the will of the people
well wait until you see because it's I
thought
Airheads
I don't care about areas but whatever I
mean d seems kind of loud to be honest D
was too harsh yeah I agree
they wound up on B
sour skittles
that seems fine to me
I feel anything incredible that feels
too low for me I think so where can I
try sour skittles EST here that's too
high for me do we have too high way too
high wait do we have sour potatoes here
uh let's see we got a lot of candy I
definitely want to try
the sour skittles I can't remember I
could not find sour skittles oh really
oh you know why because they're so
popular they were sold out
I think Bee's fine but it's I don't I
mean I'd be happy with that being on the
sea who says it's too high
Lena and I what did you guys rate it
probably like a d probably a little for
me too it's sour for like 90 for one
second yeah
yeah oh interesting and it rips up your
mouth like it's it's pretty painful to
you it starts to burn after a few of
them yeah what burns your throat no you
know you're like not in your upper mouth
yeah like Cuts your mouth yeah oh my
gosh [ __ ] are you guys eating no they're
right they're right I know what you guys
are talking about [ __ ] yeah yeah
it's just like like a harsh sour
Dan I just remembered something that's
more important than this [ __ ] candy
[ __ ] what you owe us oh
oh god really not right before the party
yeah let's not do it always something
I'm gonna be you've been putting this
[ __ ] off dude you guys know what
it does and you were supposed to eat it
it almost sent me to the hospital I'm
just [ __ ] with you
but we're going to a party
that's not fair I'll do it I'll do it
next week when we don't have a party
immediately after the show I will not I
will do it I promise we have a guess
oh we do have guests next week but they
can watch
well whenever you know whenever just any
time that we don't have a party to go to
in like 30 minutes so I will do it
Hershey's kiss you know I don't I'm not
a fan of Hershey's chocolate but I do
love the kiss and I'm fine with B you
think that belongs I think that's wild
yeah I also think that's wild wild west
Beach
suck these nuts you said they what
they're just milk chocolate nah they're
iconic you guys are haters they taste
huge literally have you had a Hershey's
kiss love yeah okay whatever yes bad
kids you're ahead European chocolate is
way better way better oh here we go
there's something I mean you're right
but here we go these are like f for me I
like the texture you bite into it it's
got some body yeah I feel like Hershey's
candy bars are awful but the kisses are
good
I'm with Urban chocolates so wait then
who don't talk about our chocolate and
eggs oh it should be G for garbage
facts I like Hershey's Kisses yeah I
mean I think I ran into B
oh my God as a kid I [ __ ] love these
man yeah I gave it I believe an a there
you go God I know
it's not suspicious that both of the
people not born in the U.S things
otherwise you guys just don't know you
guys don't know I know like it's fine
listen I get it you guys don't like it
yeah Hershey's chocolate sucks but the
kisses are good yeah that's what I'm
saying it's fine you guys have been
brainwashed bro I've had European
chocolate love I know I know what it
tastes like it's good okay but come on
don't be such a xenophobe bro
they'll be so anti-American yeah you're
trying to move here okay respect the
kids yeah true true I love Hershey's
exactly
okay Sweet Tarts was at a and I agree
I'm not a fan sweethearts are okay I
think it's a c do we have sweetheart
uh those I saw there's retards there are
yeah we have so much candy yeah I don't
know how they wound up on a although
people go back and be like Dan you were
the one that insisted it was that high
but I don't know that we have them in
here let me just
no nothing there's this sour ones right
chewy sour uh yeah I can I can bring
they're a little here oh this little bit
there's a little
yeah I think those are like there's
probably like two in there oh these are
outers okay okay no these are horrible
hate them
foreign
I thought they were chewy like
but they're powder well you think
they're horrible I hate it
I like it do you like munching on Chalk
things do you like they were a
not because of me dude it's just Toms
yeah yeah Tom's is medicine I eat it
because it's medicine you're like that's
good for medicine Sweet Tarts are just
Tums I like the little it's got a little
like punch of tartness in it though Tums
though it's C at best that's all I'm
saying yeah the berry flavored Tums they
have quite a bite now here's our uh
here's a new uh entry that's interesting
Lifesavers oh yeah do we have these here
I think it's perfect and see no we don't
have Lifesavers oh my God
I hate these things unless they're the
gummy kind of unless they're gummies
yeah oh no they're
oh same thing here I was thinking of the
gummies for some reason I I asked Dan
when we were taking when I was taking
the poll are these the gummies or the
hard kind
of hard ones yeah not that good so
they're pretty mid yeah yeah so is it
the gummy or is it the hard one it's the
hard one it's the hard one okay yeah
Mars bar I [ __ ] love Mars it's got
the nougat it's got the caramel it's
amazing
and you guys are [ __ ] haters
and cowards do we have everything we do
we don't have any Mars there's a few of
these that are on this list that are
missing
because we added the more like obscure
ones and I don't know it's not obscure I
don't know I've never heard of it what I
have never heard of Mars really that's
an everyday store globally never classic
oh I learned about them from we did like
an exchange program when I was in
seventh grade with Australian kids yeah
and they were the ones like my my
Australian boyfriend from that sent me
is in Israel we have them and it's
really cool American Kids
bar
no go to the grocery store they have
Mars Bars she did and she she got all
this candy it wasn't there Mars Mars
Mars owns a lot of the [ __ ] like the the
name the company Mars yeah but they're
actual Mars Bars not I love popular it's
got everything good it's like Snickers
but without the peanuts right and it's
just nougat and caramels it's awesome
yeah
you can see that being good
I'm gonna go down to Milk Duds you hate
her asses I love Milk Duds man yeah you
must have been the one to inflate that
because I didn't like those
blood
nobody likes milk does nobody's with me
chewy chocolate caramelly treats
treasures and treats I rated it load
just because they are really good but um
after each one just gets caught in your
teeth and it just really hurts yeah yeah
it's a lot of work
I threw a couple in my mouth earlier my
jaw actually started hurting yeah
I'm not super interested in like caramel
usually me too it deters me
so you guys put it 100 now why are you
guys gonna hate 100 Grand okay this
[ __ ] is amazing have you tried this I
don't remember what this one is caramel
chocolate this this I was legitimately
mad about because this is probably my
favorite candy I'm with you though like
what the [ __ ] it is beyond EST here
let's not be honest they're so stale you
got one of those for me let me let me
reevaluate yeah
100 Grand yeah can I have one Sam dude
it's really good
yes we should go ahead guys pass me one
of them hundred grand I'll tell you I'm
calling a vote on this one
I think I rated it I rated it like b or
something but I haven't had one in a
long time so I accept B but D is a
disrespectful
it's asked here without a doubt what I
wouldn't even put an S to be honest with
these apps but I would put it at least B
I think D is appropriate
my opinion but why
um do you just not like caramel is that
what's going on that's true I don't
really like caramel
I love caramel man
what y'all think
we're finding it oh
[Music]
but if we're talking about caramel
not a fan
what is it I live for a caramel it's
just too chewy I don't like to chew okay
I need crunchy chocolate like by far but
the best candy to me is mini Crunch bars
this one has Crunch and chew I don't
want the chew the best of both women the
rice part is kind of like stale I don't
like that could be old
I wonder if it has an eat by date
keep this [ __ ] by [ __ ] yeah or let's
see
I don't know what all this [ __ ] means
all right whatever we ain't got all day
here for the 100 grand
you guys get one okay
Dan is sampling the 100 grand
not bad it's not bad
no it's one of your favorite
I think I think it's really good I like
the it's probably my favorite I like the
rice they are pretty good I like the
rice
this is my first time having it and it's
really good actually thank you Lena did
not try it before you voted on it
because you got it's here
this is why democracy doesn't work this
is why we need Representatives the
people you gotta go out and vote
[ __ ]
you said it's MB
what would you rate it Lena
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
I think the B is appropriate it has a
little of everything I love it there it
is thank you Lena
I'm not feeling it no right I'm not
feeling it at all
[Music]
it's just sophisticated candy
the plebians and peasants don't like it
moving on
I think this is probably going to go up
to a b though if we're being fair
so we're going to put it back to be
Abba Zaba my mom the only reason I know
that abazab is my mom
is this King out yeah but it's yellow
I don't see that that's an aggressive
close enough yeah
chewy I've never even heard of that yeah
so this is interesting this is an
old-timey treat it's an old-timey my
mom's favorite candy
and she so what it is is it's Taffy with
peanut butter in the middle it's very
odd but I had one and it it does slap it
is quite good if I'm being honest
somebody else should try because I think
I know what my score is going to be you
should try it I mean I already had one
today not gonna be good did you guys
I'm familiar with Abba's album I've had
Amazon before not not really a fan AV
not particularly a Taffy guy in general
though to be honest so I'll try it right
now
yeah try I would like you guys to see
you guys try it for the first time
because it's a very interesting candy I
mean it's very different I'll give it
that yeah
another one there's nothing quite like
an Abba Zaba but yeah I'm not I don't
love it
[Music]
packaging is uh a little difficult I'll
say it's old school bro I don't know
it's an old timer it's an old timey
candy
you don't like it you hate it
after G
[Laughter]
what would you rather eat habazaba or
[ __ ]
no I it's
it's not bad but the reason I don't like
it is it reminds me of Middle Eastern
candy where it's like two things are
mixed that shouldn't be like salty and
yeah yeah I don't know we put fruit in
our cakes and [ __ ] and I hate that I
hate that
I hate that okay I guess it's
appropriate ID does anyone like it
some candies you wonder how it became a
thing because it seems like everybody
hates it no this is good you like that
okay
how do we all have such different
opinions literally just sugar all this
it's all five percent or chocolate with
a mixture of all good well this is bad
it's just all sugar it's so much more
than sugar it's the packaging the
delivery
yeah that it brings up to you okay
candy is like so candy is nostalgic
true Queen I was gonna say I think a lot
of a lot of the reason why I haven't
tried some of these is because I think
the packaging is so ugly and I feel like
I wouldn't buy it yeah but I think your
brand is so ugly oh really it's the
worst it is you're right and then it's
white like what yeah no wait it's what
am I eating paper it's not white no no
you're confusing the Abba Zaba Oh I
thought oh oh I'm still talking about
this guy yeah got it 100 Grand I never
even tried that until I was like in my
20s because the packaging is so [ __ ]
like it looks like it looks it looks
like an old person candy yeah yeah
that's super I mean I don't hate Abba
Zaba it's kind of interesting
okay so next up La is the Warhead the
dreaded
Warhead extra sour now I have a bone to
pick with um some of y'all because it's
Buzz beats here yeah which is kind of
generous I'll say that but what's your
what's your favorite is that the one
that's super super I mean if it's not
clear by now from my feelings on some of
the other ones I am obviously a sour
candy head love sour candy all about it
and Warheads they're the ultimate sour
candy now I can understand
not having it in you to be able to
handle a warhead I get that that's fine
not everybody it's not for everyone but
just say it Dan they're coward yeah oh
they're being they're being kind of
they're being [ __ ] let's let's be
honest they're being [ __ ] [ __ ]
they're [ __ ] [ __ ] maybe you're just
being a Sour Puss Dan
he forced me to say that basically I was
being much more respectable anyway not
pushed you had to make it because that's
a great misogynist over there
for a bunch of questions but dropping it
to D tier just because you can't handle
the Warhead is [ __ ] up that's [ __ ]
up do we have warheads in here yeah so
let's all do a warhead right now
together let's do it
let's see who wimps out I love Warheads
man I agree with Dan
what happened I
know Olivia is trying to get out of
doing more products okay
okay
plus it's like the memories tied with it
yes childhood memories yeah I think
Warheads was a big part of all of our
childhood I mean that's how you proved
your your medal right the playground
same with Fireballs yeah yeah fireballs
oh we had that on the candy video I like
Atomic uh Warhead or Atomic Fireballs
better than the Warheads but it's a wild
ride yeah does Warhead still come in
like small Rockets
hey maybe they didn't do that in America
yeah they they came in like a little
plastic rocket oh that's so cute yeah we
got bad news Dan says I've never seen
that no Warheads no Warheads
all right well we don't have much time
anyways can you find a picture love yeah
I'll try to find it you guys real okay
so moving on
you guys moved Junior Mints from B to e
why y'all hitting on jobs that's a wild
decline it's a dog [ __ ] candy it's no
timey candy
it's just milk it's just chocolate and
nuts everyone loves chocolate and mint
you're showing you're really showing
your age here you don't like mint chip
ice cream you're being up yeah I was
um I don't really no that's a different
ball game I was gonna say the crew got
younger that's why that's a different
ball game you can't compare you're just
a Seinfeld fan that's the thing right
I've always liked Junior Miss even when
I was a kid you [ __ ] animals
I love it but why why e like nobody else
likes them but me nobody I think you
might stand alone on this
wait I like them okay mint and chocolate
thank you
honestly before Ethan I never knew about
mint stuff like for some reason but he
got me hooked up on
chocolate mint ice cream yeah now it's
the only flavor that I eat yeah it's
it's the best flavor and now I buy like
chocolate mint
okay all the time
go ahead that's Junior mint those are
the people who invented mint chocolate
that's like the
oh you know what that is that's the
Manhattan Project of candy
yep
it's good right so how you all going to
get it to eat me and Ela and Sam like it
so how y'all gonna [ __ ] I like it too so
what's going on I'm gonna be a huge fan
but this is [ __ ] them up I even put my
candy down there like that I rated it
low
um I think I rated f
there's no crunch literally just a bite
that's the thing I don't like you're
making you're staking your whole
argument on oh you guys don't like mint
chocolate right it's not in chocolate is
fine yeah I'm not like the biggest fan
but it's fine like I I like mint
chocolates
those things I could use a little more
texture I'll give you that yeah yeah
kind of gets like I was just gonna say
that I would eat it but it's not what I
would prefer yeah okay so you would eat
it so how bad would it be I I agree with
that I if I'm buying candy at the store
this will not yeah that's not happening
[Music]
I mean yeah I would say D or E tier and
it ended up in e
I don't know I'll give you B might be
high but e is a [ __ ] outrage
oh and then here's one more new one uh
runts yeah this is a big one for my
childhood it runs [ __ ] soaked wait do
we have we don't have them I looked
everywhere on yourself see when I was a
kid they had um the bubble gum machines
where you put in a quarter and then it
dispenses a bunch of runs and it tastes
like that it tastes you know what runs
taste like the uh
the waiting area outside of a Toys R Us
that's being closed in like a month
and that's everything I know what it is
for Real it was the uh runs is the
section yeah they have that in Israel
too in in Michigan's like yeah right
here and everybody loved the banana ones
yeah
like dessert in malls or something like
an ice skating rink that is the Toys R
Us candy you know that perfectly yeah
well you know what as much as I am
nostalgic for runs I agree they suck but
I would always go for it like all kids
eat them and yeah nobody
I don't think it's an F you guys are
[ __ ] monsters all this Astound you
bro
yeah it's just it's you know instead you
didn't like Toys R Us candy
Toys R Us was gone bro okay so there it
is so now let's go to the most
interesting part all right we asked the
fans on Twitter we set up a Google our
party technically starts in 15 minutes
we're gonna wrap we're almost done yeah
this will be the last thing so um we
tweeted out the res and the results were
pretty shocking we had 50 000 Super
Troopers voting on their candy each one
was rated on a scale same as us F to S
okay and there was a lot of pull
basically lots of polarization as you
can see this is basically based on which
candies
um so interesting so what we did is we
took the highest particular letter score
for the candy and put it in that bracket
so these candies for example had the
most in terms of all the people that
voted for it s was the most you know
what I mean
does that make sense
we didn't average it out yeah yeah it's
just whichever tier one yeah devotes
yeah
people do Eminem yes there you go this
is so outrageous bro
I mean it's [ __ ] up how you gonna do
them dirty like that that's so funny
that there's nothing in D and E
yep skip right over those just threw
everything in f look at how over
so I think what this does is it really
gives us a definitive list I mean this
is yeah a statistically significant
test
and the people have spoken I mean the
s's here are pretty solid Twix peanut M
M's
Reese's Peanut Butter Cups I hate those
and sour skittles that one threw me off
I see it's that it's the peanut M M's
for me the rest of those are all solid
S's
Reese's Peanut Butter Cups I don't know
if they're s but they are good they're
iconic dude they're the best
I like the edges bro the edges are the
chocolate part absolutely right but the
middle sometimes you get too big of a
middle bite and you're like that ain't
peanut butter the Reese's had a very
high s uh percentage too it's like 52 of
votes were asked so Reese's really is
number one
like that's the most universally loved
I'd have to go back and check but it was
very high yeah oh can we get that are
you able to access I want to know which
is the most universal they loved candy
if you can access that easily but if not
it's fine he's looking yeah so KitKat
comes in as the only a and kick out is a
great candy so I accept that the cat's
Rock now B we get into some contentious
uh stuff here but the people have spoken
Starbursts beloved by many as a bee
regular M M's Sour Patch Kids uh
Hershey's cookies and cream
Snickers
Jolly Ranchers Milky Way
Skittles Reese's Pieces butter finger
nerds AirHeads and love yes the
Hershey's kiss the people have spoken
you hater
go to Ikea and buy some Swedish
chocolate
and we get it dude you hate America
movies unlike Hershey's because it's not
[ __ ] drenched in salt
right hey come on that's me
shout outs
I need too much candy dude I think I'm
so proud
my body's in shock oh I know NC is the
Crunch bar thank you that was not me a
Crunch bar which I love it's the rice
it's the chocolate it's all happening I
love crunch too the best Three
Musketeers for me is there's too many
peanuts I can't [ __ ] with them
fun dip overrated candy in my opinion
but there it is it's disgusting when
kids [ __ ] with fun dip it's disgusting
they end up looking like how you look
right now
yeah and they get they get it you know
what it is you have like a sugar stick
yeah and a patch of powder yeah and you
dip the stick and you suck on it and
it's just it turned into such a [ __ ]
gross mess it's really nasty so fun
um and then down so this is so these are
all F there's no D and then everybody
just straight f-bombed
down here Lifesaver Abu Zaba Milk Duds
Sweet Tarts Hershey's see love and I
think this is interesting to point out
Hershey's is f but the Hershey's Kiss is
a b and that's what I'm saying there's
something there yeah it's not based on
Flavor it's just because it's an acute
packaging you know it's that's not true
wait you mentioned Three Musketeers has
too many peanuts in it I don't think it
has peanuts all right yeah Three
Musketeers is like kind of the fluffy uh
you're probably are you thinking of um
payday yeah maybe I'm thinking okay then
uh down here Mr goodwar Jr Matt
underground Rolo Tony Browntown Dum Dums
Mars runts Smarties Tootsie Pops
both dum-dums and Tootsie Pops down at
the bottom just tells me that there is a
large lollipop anti-lollipop basis going
on Tootsie Pops yeah you're gonna [ __ ]
with Tootsie Pops Warheads baby roof
Almond Joy Whoppers dots Tootsie Rolls
the [ __ ] hamburger
chewy wow you guys have wrote that
insane Hot Tamales I love Hot Tamales
Twizzlers
Whoppers candy corn yarks payday and
Twizzlers so all hate
these candies should not even exist but
there's one here which is interesting a
lot of you guys have never tried it and
this is a popular Mexican candy and I
tried this once as a kid and
it traumatized me it's [ __ ] horrific
and I don't mean peace and love to my
Mexican friends and family out there but
you can't I love the food love the
cuisine but this candy is [ __ ] up okay
so here's how it worked you take the top
off everyone's got one yep I don't even
know how you're supposed to take it I
haven't had one of these since I was a
kid either a little scared how'd you get
it off just with Force you just pull it
it just tastes like
um like a fruit bar so so look at this
look at this
it comes out oh it's all key down here
here I'll demonstrate oh wait I'm
showing screen too all right I got it
here it's somebody who is not green
screen yeah there you go there you go so
you push it out of here
and you suck on the goo yep it's so wild
and then the thing is you save it for
later and it's got like your spit and
goo it's just
it's not a not exaggerating there
yeah
so you push it is really hard it's like
a little cartridge and then you push and
it comes out
yeah I don't know why so I think these
are like old or some [ __ ] because
nobody's buying this [ __ ] it's been
sitting on the [ __ ] shelf okay
true
not not for me pretty wild one right
there yeah yeah not great there it is
though I mean the Swedish eat on like
candies that are like 90 sugars or I
mean salt so I love maybe you should not
even talk also there what there is some
good uh Mexican candy by the way some
very good Mexican candy is just this one
the lollipops hit super hard lollipops
you know what I loved when I was a kid
do you guys remember uh Lucas powder
you know what I'm talking about no
maybe if you see the thing you'll
remember
there
oh it looks similar looks familiar what
is it it's like this [ __ ] it's like
it's like salt in like chili powder [ __ ]
and you just like eat it straight yeah
it smells pretty wild and I think
there's sweetness to it too yeah I think
it's like a it's literally comes in like
this little Shaker I remember in
elementary school kids thought it was
funny to dare each other to uh to snort
it like it was cocaine oh my God
yeah all right but we really have to
wrap it up guys we're so happy to be
back thank you guys it's been a holiday
uh Bonanza happy Halloween to everybody
happy Halloween happy safe holiday we
gotta run for a party and we'll be back
on um
happy Halloween yeah happy halloweeners
everybody
and we'll be back is this the one the
winner Ian the highest most beloved
candy is
oh the most hated candy is Abba Zaba
and the most loved is Reese's with 54
same 54 s there you go
[Applause]
uh a marketing thing they seem to be
like ingrained in like great commercials
or something I don't know
I I have a little bit of a cliffhanger
if I may the duster wine Kavanaugh look
like Harvard Weinstein website is
getting attacked right now and it's down
I wonder who that is wait it's getting
ddosed it's down it's
going down but like they overwhelmed it
with request like Adidas I don't know
I'm talking to the to the like web
service that I'm working with and
they're work they're having their admins
look at it right now that's awesome
driving wait there's actually Ryan Kev
there's lots of Kev updates but we'll
talk about on Wednesday and maybe if you
guys want to talk about the whole
cancellation thing on Wednesday too in
more detail but anyway we really have to
go happy Halloween everybody thanks for
watching it's great to be back I missed
you guys love you guys thank you thank
you peace and love peace and love
I'll come back
[Music]